thank you madam chair i'm michael ivoice
of hooksett
representing
merrimack district 24
and i'm here a co-sponsor of
house bill 1159 um i was not ready to
speak on it
i was hoping i wouldn't have to
because this is not something that
i speak about lightly
um
but the prime sponsor isn't here
so the this day
um
november 7th we
want to commemorate
the date
and recognize it as
the day for the victims
of this
ideology totalitarian ideology that was
that came into power a little over a
hundred years ago
um in russia
uh under the bolshevik
regime
and um
it's been with us since then and it's
been tried in as the bill states about
40 other nations
it spread through the world
and
it caused
many
millions
of deaths
probably over 100 million
some people say between 100 and 200
million deaths who are caused by this
ideology by these
experiments and this is something that
we should
this is probably the
biggest evil that we lived through so
far
and we should hope to not repeat it
that's why this date is being recognized
in multiple states um
something very crucial to human survival
14 states have legislation that
commemorate november 7th as the date for
the victims of communism
this is also an international
recognized date more or less
because again this dates back to the
bolshevik revolution of russia which
began
the regimes
and the slaughter
of you know 100 million people
um the bill list
all the other many other regimes
throughout the world that has have tried
this ideology have tried this
absolute power given to the leaders
it didn't work out
for them either we're talking about
china
under mao we're talking about
vietnam
ho chi minh cambodia under ballpark
cuba
so
this is why um i'm a co-sponsor of the
bill
i
urge you to pass
this bill commemorating the victims
so that
we do not have
victims anymore or at least we remember
um
how not to do it next time around so
sorry i was not ready
um thank you
thank you are there any
questions seeing the oh
no okay
thank you very much for your testimony
representative samsic
um
thank you madam chair and committee
members for this opportunity to speak in
support of hb 1159
while i'm not a really big fan or
supporter of
memorial days
or proclamations
in this case i still would like to speak
to this particular bill
i'm here today and i handed out my oral
my written testimony to all of you and i
have extra copies if you didn't get them
i'm here today to submit personal
testimony in support of hb 1159.
in fact i and my family are exactly the
victims of communism that are mentioned
in this bill
while i was only six years old when my
parents fled communist hungary in 1956
and did not personally feel persecuted
many of my family members and friends
suffered under that government including
imprisonment torture and various forms
of harassment
one of my uncles who was a jesus priest
and a representative of the vatican in
hungary was arrested and tortured while
in prison
other relatives had been banished from
living near their relatives
or provided with
only inadequate housing and relatively
lowly jobs
while their children suffered various
forms of discrimination
my own father who came from an
aristocratic family but who was not
involved with politics at all
was never allowed to keep a job very
long and was labeled an enemy of the
people
we also had many friends of our family
who suffered various forms of
persecution
so i understand firsthand what the
communist hungarian government did to
many hungarians
this is why since 2016 i have been
hosting an annual remembrance here at
the state house at the plaque that
commemorates the 1956 hungarian
revolution
attended by the hungarian council in
boston and numerous hungarian americans
in new england
and this year including
one of the co-sponsors of this bill
my family's experience was also partly
the reason why in 1971
when i was a physics student at the
university of heidelberg in germany
i joined amnesty international the most
well-known human rights organization
worldwide
i wanted to contribute in some way to
working for the release of political
prisoners worldwide who were imprisoned
in violation of the internationally
recognized human rights who amnesty
called prisoners of conscience
as some of you may remember in 1971 the
world was politically quite different
from what it is today
some of the prisoners that i had was
working on behalf of during the 30 years
that i worked for amnesty
included
a jewish citizen of the soviet union
a political activist in east germany
a cultural activist in the hungarian
part of romania
a labor union activist in brazil
a socialist in czechoslovakia
and opponents of various military
dictatorships at the time in spain
greece taiwan
uruguay as well as for a journalist in
hungary
i learned much over those years about
different cultures and about human
rights violations including torture
during the course of many years of
working on these cases it became clear
to me
that no ideology has a monopoly on human
rights violations or torture
whether we are talking about the nazi
atrocities against the jews in europe or
the pogroms instigated by stalin
human beings are the victims of both
ideologies and authoritarian governments
i could pick up any particular prisoner
case sheet
and if i covered up the country of
origin and just read the details of the
case
i could not tell you whether that
government was a communist government a
military dictatorship or just an
authoritarian regime
and in fact the victims of such
governments
could care less what their torturers
were using as justification
for example the nazi government arrested
and killed political opponents
religious students such as members of
the white rose
conscientious objectors
homosexuals people with disabilities
labor union leaders and the proponents
of democratic rights
they were an equal opportunity
persecutor
as are most dictatorships
because of my experience working in
human rights i have developed a great
empathy for all victims of human rights
violations
it is still shocking to me that even the
countries of the world that signed on to
the 1948 universal declaration of human
rights
that they are today still violating many
of those promises
i thank the sponsors of this bill for
acknowledging the victims of communism
but i would respectfully ask them to
consider all victims persecuted for
exercising their human rights
this committee could do that by
expanding the range of victims and
designating a victims of oppression
memorial day
and since december 10th is already
recognized worldwide as a human rights
as human rights day it would make sense
to use that day to remember the victims
of oppression on that day
thank you very much i'd be glad to
answer any questions
thank you are there any questions
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1159
okay seeing none i'll close the public
hearing
representative sentence so you have a
motion
uh yes i'll make a motion uh
to
for house bill
1159 and expedient to legislate
second
and representative leckus
did we just end public testimony and
enter
an executive session yes okay i didn't
hear that i'm sorry thank you i wasn't
explicit enough my fault i did however
end the hearing
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh yes uh
so communism uh
you know i read the first volume of uh
the ghoul like archipelago by
uh alexandra scholskinskin and what that
book taught me is that communism is
it's worse than you can imagine
um but this kind of bill
you know we've kind of decided as a
committee that this kind of waters down
the actual underlining issue and the
best way to handle this kind of thing is
to
uh
is to not put into statue you know
decorations
to order the governor to make
declarations
as such and it'd be better served
in a different way
thank you representative blackis
thank you um
i agree and um
i'm you know supporting the ital sort of
uncomfortably with a heavy heart i'm
you know i'm very aware of
of you know what happened what the
communists have done my father fought on
the anti-communist side in the greek
civil war
i had a great grandmother who left
moscow in 1913 a good year to get out
but actually i think
as was mentioned by the representative
who spoke
the proper way to the more effective way
of commemorating is for groups of people
to organize things like the
commemoration of the hungarian
revolution
and
they can ask the governor petition the
governor to sign a resolution which
he'll generally do
the problem is there's a lot of these uh
in statute and if you go and ask most
people
they won't even know what most of them
are about
and so you know they get put in statute
and forgotten probably the governor's
staff on the right days gives them
something to sign and it's issues a
press release and nobody notices
anything
so i applaud people who
in groups who put the effort into
commemorating such days and
but i don't think this is a
useful way of handling it thank you
thank you representative
thank you madam chair i will also
support the ito
and let me try to rephrase it what uh
but representative lekka said
this committee
receives a lot of requests for
days honoring an event
and we have so many of them
that and there's no way really
to
for the state
recognize them other than just put them
on this calendar
and so
there has been a policy of this
committee
not to
to to
to deem these bills in expedient to
legislate
in the hopes that those people who are
[Music]
dedicated and committed to a certain
cause
will
reach out to the governor for
proclamation and will with within their
group
promote
the
the cause of the bill thank you
thank you other comments representative
goalie
thank you madam chair
and i too will support the itl um
and
i was unaware and i'm sure
a number of folks here were probably
unaware that november 7th is already a
national holiday a national celebrated
nationally for this
this is already
in the books as a national uh event
and
as we see we have a number in statute
already of days and i think this would
be just another one that would go in
there and i'm not sure
whether it be once it's in celebrated
continually or if it's better to be done
on the national day and have the
governor proclaim has a better option
thank you
thank you representative
well so was martin luther king day
national but we didn't hesitate to make
it a state uh holiday either so
look i wish this bill weren't here all
right i don't like these proclamations
but the fact is whether this is ignored
or not ignored it's too it's just too
important to
let principle override this even if it's
ignored
so i'm all for the itl but i'm not going
to vote for it i'm going to vote for
this
as i said i wish it weren't here i have
no personal experience although i find
my from my family tree that i would have
been jewish enough for hitler uh
fortunately nobody they were all
well the left came over here to get jobs
i guess
anyway um
so
uh look in addition to being a state
representative i
every night i go to bed i read
right wing magazine it's pretty
responsible national review and i'm
distraught at where this where the world
totalitarianism oppression it just seems
to be every nation
people are
thirst for power we even saw it here
uh what
too much philosophy i'm done thank you
representative allegra
thank you madam chair
i am
too will support the itl on this bill
although i do so regretfully
i
have to cite what i always cite i'm
obligated to cite that we have 65 000
pages
of rsas over there on the shelf
and
to be passing legislation for this sort
of thing is difficult
especially
since
i've spoken to so many people
like representatives uh yakubovich and
samsel who
lived behind the iron curtain
and many who
were senior and remember very well the
goings-on
they tell me what i already knew and
that's why i do this regretfully support
the itl
they tell me what i already know and
that is that at this particular time the
united states is in the midst of a
communist insurgency
and
so
we need to be vigilant we need to
recognize it
but another memorial day i don't think
is in order thank you
representative
schuett
thank you madam chair
as someone of polish heritage
and i think we're all aware that the
polls suffered
greatly under both nazism and
joseph stalin
i regretfully will vote itl on this bill
with a word to the sponsors that this
committee usually recommends that you
actually are going to gain more public
recognition
of this issue by going to the governor
and having him do a press conference
the first splash when something like
this gets put into the rsa
yes it gets noticed but after a few
years it's just sitting there in statute
and it's up to people whether or not
they pay attention to the date
so i would urge you to please approach
the governor
and ask him to make this proclamation
yearly
on a personal basis and i think he would
thank you madam chair
thank you and i would have to agree that
probably most of the committee would be
delighted to sign such a request
representative fellows thank you
like so many people on this committee
i'm going to vote ito
i think this is a very important subject
and i would like
ways for people
the public to learn more about what
happened the people who have first-hand
experience are have mostly passed away
at this point
but
just having a proclamation day is not
going to make people more informed about
this issue it's more important that
there be things like pbs shows and
they teach more about it in school
and there are just other avenues that
would inform people at a proclamation
they really won't help much thank you
okay
actually i will mention that one of the
co-sponsors representative campbell's
came to this country from cuba as an
adult so he he understands the the issue
representative bailey
i'm going to oppose the itl because i
realize that we have a principle here of
not
keeping this sort of thing going but we
have made exceptions
and this hundreds of millions of dead
strikes me as something to make an
exception about
thank you
hey
anyone else representative site for a
second time
we don't need personal experience to
know this horror
that's irrelevant i mean it's relevant
to that individual but these 100 million
people that died i don't need
i've i'm done
anyone else representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
well as one of the older or perhaps the
oldest member of the committee and
somebody who lived in europe for
five and a half years back in the
sixties i was present for
having to be out of the uh out of the
the country of germany
uh where i was living at the time at
that par at the particular moment when
the berlin wall
was was commenced
there wasn't a wall initially they
strung barbed wire along certain streets
blocked people from looking out or
climbing out the windows of their
apartments
which were technically in east berlin
where the sidewalk
below them was in west berlin um
and initially it was a horror story in
many ways
um
but but i uh so i i
lived through the
the that period in germany when uh when
some of the most evil aspects
of um
totalitarian regimes of the of the
eastern of eastern europe were
practicing their horrors
but
i am concerned about
especially the
call for action beginning on line 21
and especially you look at lines 22 23
which
urged cities towns school administrative
unit school districts as well as state
colleges state colleges and universities
throughout the state to observe the day
in an appropriate manner including but
not limited to education on topics
such as mao tsatung in china and so
forth
so if we're prescribing a course of
action above and beyond a proclamation
we're talking about a program of
education
on these topics
that's a pretty significant undertaking
especially for younger children
who will have utterly no idea what what
they're being presented with to begin
with
and the implementation of this uh you
know would have to be very skillful so
that we don't
merely engage in indoctrination with
regard to the evils of communism
when
perhaps a more appropriate topic would
be
civil rights abuses that occur under all
kinds of governments
in some instances even our own in the
past
and so i think this is an invitation to
um either
sloppy
observation of something or
indoctrination which we would not be
happy with
so i will support the
itl motion as well with
with uh
with also with recognition of what a
number of my colleagues have said about
this
thank you
represent representative
thank you madam chair uh if i remember
correctly the cases where we made
exceptions have been for
one-time events um i think we had a
couple of them
not for
regular ones that just happen every year
for example we had the one on the
upcoming
solar eclipse here and that was at least
part had a financial
component to try and promote tourism to
the state when that happens but thank
you
any other comments
representative scitec for a third time
representative schmidt you're exactly
right on and if i thought this bill was
going anywhere i would amend it out and
try to make this a one-time celebration
but i don't think it's worth the effort
at this point
i agree
one time the the
the eclipse yes representative schmidt
the eclipse situation was one where
we're going to have to be prepared for
potentially thousands of people coming
to new hampshire not merely to observe
but also to get in and out
safely and without encumbering the
entire northern part of the state
so i agree one one time aspect is an
important one
thank you i'm more concerned with the
fact that
the two people who spoke had different
ideas on what we should do with the
spill
i mean victims of communism
is different from victims of oppression
and
changing the date just doesn't seem to
be the right thing to do
in any anyone else
all right seeing no other comments the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1159
and like the clerk can call the role
rhodes
yes
the clerk votes no representative
pearson
representative pearson i'm going to vote
no but i'm not going to oppose consent
representative yakubovic
no
representative lekkis
yes representative allegro
yes
representative bailey
no
representative santo nestaso
yes
representative valenzara no
representative goalie
yes representative showed
yes
representative
schmidt
yes representative marsh
yes representative fellows
yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes
i don't think this belongs on consent
there's five dissents
even if there were only one i think it
is
something of of note
the vote is 12 to 5.
the vote is 12 to 5 so the motion passes
this will be on the regular calendar
is someone going to be writing a
minority report
yup representative you can't write a
minority report represented allegro you
voted for it
and therefore he's
he's writing the majority report is
somebody writing a minority report
yes okay representative yakubovic will
be writing a minority report
and while we're in executive session
representative pearson
representative pearson i believe you
have a motion on 1549
um
let me find my copy
yes
we
[Music]
we heard that last monday on the 25th
1549 special duty hours by re worked by
retired police
so
sure
thank you madam chair
i'm gonna move itl on 1549.
sounded like goalie
please keep your mic off unless you're
actually speaking please we keep cutting
off
did you have a second madam chair
yes representative goalie second
i'd like to speak to your motion
representative pearson i would thank you
one of the things that
keeps the
the the theory and function of the
pension system going
is a balance of investment returns and
income
and one of the things that has become
slightly
popular
is
a lot of things that are reducing the
income stream to that system
this particular bill and we're supposed
to look at these as standalone but this
does kind of tie into another one that
we're we're also hearing
specifically in the the issue here is
specifically the exclusion of hours
on
what would be special duty we we've
already have concerns over the amount of
hours worked that retirees are doing as
it is
and to
start breaking out subgroups of
different types of things and not
counting hours here and counting hours
there makes an extraordinarily
complicated system even more so
so i think that we really should be
focusing on
the holistic
inclusion of hours worked
and not start to break them off into
subgroups and specialties and things of
that nature so that is that is the main
premise of why i think this uh piece of
legislation needs to be italed
representative goalie do you wish to
speak to your second
thank you madam chair uh yes i
i think
looking at this
like representative pearson said we've
always looked to reduce the number of
hours
well i would prefer to see a reduction
in the hours worked i think this here
calling on not including special duty
hours
um
you see it is right in it uh special
duty law enforcement so they're still
doing law enforcement whether directing
traffic or not they're expected to carry
out their duties um for that reason
alone i think that those hours should be
counted thank you
representative
um
you may not have i'm not sure how many
heard but representative emerick when he
was introducing this said almost under
his breath if these special duty hours
do not earn money towards retirement
why should they be counted against you
after retirement source for the goose is
sourced for the gander
i'd like to enlarge this for a second
because i've been thinking a lot about
if you don't mind uh i'll try to make
this fast
we have 12 minutes i'll try to keep it
to 11. the
we wonder about these people working
part-time
when they could have full-time officers
paying down the uaal how about something
like this
you say to somebody who's working
part-time
you want to work part-time for this town
hold the retirement system harmless
you contribute towards the uaal
we can't charge you an employment fee
but you can hold the retirement system
harmless as it would have been held
harmless if they had gotten a regular
officer so take your pick you don't have
to worry
that's a thought i'm not going to man
the ramparts but if anybody if it grows
any legs i'd be happy to work with it
thank you representative rhodes
madam chair i i would respect that um
representative pearson seems to have a
response that seems pretty important so
i would yield and re go after him
okay representative
thank you madam chair um with reference
to
representative scitec's comments
and what i was going to say i did ask
the question
during the hearing
if there were still officers who were
able to
work special details and have that count
towards their retirement and the answer
was yes approximately eighteen hundred
so in difference to those officers who
are able to work these special details
and have it count towards their
retirement i would say that's a pretty
large number and we should i teal this
bill for now perhaps in the future if
the number is much smaller it's
something to consider thank you thank
you representative pearson
now this is in reference to
the the idea that representative scitec
has brought forward there is one there
is one problem with that in the sense
that if you are going to charge these
folks
and you're going to withdraw
monies from their
pay to pay the pension system now you're
starting to run into irs things you're
starting to run into federal pension
laws that involve the prohibition of
that exact thing so that's though i i'm
not opposed to the the theory and what
you're getting at there um you just as
of right now cannot do that if you're
going to withdraw it's going to have to
become part of the process
that process being and again to remind
the folks you know there have been
substantial efforts made against double
dipping into this system
and when you start
bringing people back in virtually
full-time roles you are doing exactly
that you are permitting someone to to
practically work full-time while also
collecting their retirement that is not
healthy for the system it's not how the
system was intended to function
and i think that the problems that the
representative schuett made in reference
to those that are still active and and
able to count these
also exacerbates that thank you
senator rhodes
thank you madam chairman
so i i believe
that it was representative o'brien that
had asked the question about
if if there was a specific reason that
there needed to be officers that was
doing this special duty because if
indeed they were needed to
do a duty then they would be the ones to
actually be able to step up and do that
in the event of
you know something going wrong so that
is one thing to consider that if if
other people were able to do it they
would be doing it so they are doing
police work um
the the other thing that i think is
important is
exactly what representative pearson is
saying that
once you retire so a lot of the reasons
and and we did have a gentleman that
confirmed this that one of the reasons
people retire is when they're they're
ready to be retired and once you are
retired you're actually able
to say
no i i don't want to work these
particular days or these particular
hours and you're kind of excused from
that so in the event that you start
working you know your 1500 and some
hours a year 25 hours a week i think it
related to then you turn around and you
work
20 or 25 hours at this particular job
you're essentially working more than
what a full-time
employee is working and perhaps they
need to step back a little bit before
they make that decision to retire
thank you i'd i'd like to mention that
the
employee would not be paying
uaal contribution that's an employer
responsibility
and therefore
if we tried to impose that it would be a
cost increase for the towns
they are
current many many towns are enjoying
having retired police officers because
they're cheaper than than
working police officers because you
don't have to pay the pension
contribution
so this would make it more difficult for
retired police to find a job if their
employer had to pay the ual in addition
to the
the cash on hand to the person
representative scitec of the chair is
the town wouldn't be prohibited from
paying that as an extra too
i don't believe any town would volunteer
to pay the ual well to keep to have an
officer a hand
but we would have to mandate that they
do so
if i may continue i do not like what
representative schuett and pearson have
said because they forced me to change my
mind
it's a hazard of the job representative
scitec is there any other comments
questions
all right seeing none
the motion is an expedient to legislate
on house bill 1549
by representative pearson and goalie
and the clerk can call the role
representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative show it
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes the chair
yes grand slam
17 to zero
okay the motion passes 17 to zero
without objection we'll put it on
consent
all right i think that's probably all we
can do until our next hearing
so i'll close the executive session
yeah i'm not hard but i aren't they
going to die off i mean is that their
grandfather
good morning everyone
i'm opening the hearing on house bill
1552 and i call one of the sponsors
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair
representative pamonti is unable to be
with us this morning
has a conflict but he asked me to open
the bill for him which i'm happy to do
i won't take any testimony i i am on the
assessing standards board as
some of you in the committee know
now for uh i don't know 15 or 16 years
i don't profess to any
any specific expertise in the field but
i have listened and learned a lot in my
time on the committee and i am fully in
support of this bill
because it it goes to an issue that will
be discussed by the the numerous experts
who are here from the assessing
standards board president passed
and so i hope the committee will ask
their questions when when any one of
them are testifying they know what
they're talking about so thank you very
much
okay thank you representative schmidt i
call robert gagne
the i'm the vice chair
of the assessing standards board
the chairman betsy patton i believe
couldn't be with us today so
i'm here to speak to the bill
[Music]
the uh the impetus for for for this bill
was that um
the transparency
of assessing certification
and discipline and decertification
is not where the assessing standards
board wanted it to be the intent when we
put rules in place excuse me sir you
have to be closer to the microphone
thank you
the the intent when we put the rules in
place was to have this process be
transparent
um for taxpayers for the regulating
bodies and so forth
and it turns out that because uh the
department of revenue has a
non-disclosure or
non-disclosure statute they have
interpreted that to mean that the
entirety of the assessing certification
and discipline decertification is
confidential and can't be released to
the public
this is not the intent of the asb when
we set the rules up
and we're taking this avenue to make
sure that that process is transparent
thank you we appreciate that is there
any questions
representative schuett
thank you madam chair thank you mr
gangney
is there some reason that this could not
be accomplished
by somehow changing statute to allow
the assessing standards board to do this
um
the assessing standards board
was set up to
put standards and rules in place for
assessing
but it was never an intention that the
assessing standards would be the
policing agency initially that was the
department of revenue
and
that had been working fairly well
since its inception in the early aughts
you know 2001 or two
but some issues have come up in the last
couple of years
on that transparency issue
and and we felt this was a necessary
step i can tell you that there have been
members of the public who have felt that
it should have been
an independent
licensing and service certification
board since the beginning
uh kind of like the new hampshire real
estate appraiser board of which i'm a
certified individual
we
initially thought that was
maybe too big a step and that that
between the assessing standards board
and the department of revenue that this
could be handled properly and
we don't know that that's the case
anymore
thank you
representative blackis
thank you um
rather than setting up a whole separate
board to deal with this is there
other problems with dra doing it other
than transparency because there you know
there could be statute change to make uh
that part of what they do you know have
to be transparent right right and and to
be honest we've got another track where
we've
proposed adding
some exceptions to the confidentiality
statute that they're subject to to open
up those records
but there may be some additional issues
that others will will address
i can tell you that um and and i don't
know if the department is here to speak
today
but the uh
okay um
you know there's there's been quite a
bit of activity in the last few years on
uh complaints and so forth
and
and this is my opinion by the way
i'm not sure that the um
uh
the hearings bureau that they have set
up was really set up for this kind of
thing
i think it was more set up for for
issues of taxation and appeals of
taxation whether it's rooms and meals or
business tax
and um
you know it's it's not that large a
staff where the oplc i as i understand
it is a staff of over a hundred and this
is their job is to administer
i believe about 54 boards and
commissions
um
i can tell you as a real estate
appraiser i think they've done a you
know it's been a process that's worked
pretty well
and i'm confident that that
it would be a good setup to create this
assessing certification board under the
oplc
thank you
representative scitec
other boards as have as part of their
function
discipline uh how you said that you only
do standards and testing why not
incorporate why not expand your uh
purview to
include discipline
yeah we we do have disciplinary rules
and this department of revenue that that
enforces that not the assessing we set
the standards and and the disciplinary
rules
and the department of revenue polices
that
thank you we're
other questions
representative fellows
um
can you just tell me
why
if you think that the office of
professional licensing and certification
has staff
that can
make decisions about
even if a person qualifies to be
certified or licensed because
within this statute
it's very vague it's not like
they graduated with some kind of degree
or they you know
certified by some you know assessing
national assessing
assessors standards borders something
like that so how would that even work
so we
the proposal in front of you was based
on
the statute i believe for the most part
for the new hampshire real estate
appraiser board it mirrors that
so this sets up the framework and then
rules have to be set about who qualifies
and how
and while the oplc will administer that
the assessing certification board will
oversee that for example if there's a
complaint against an assessor
the oplc would
take that complaint in determine if it's
founded do the research determine if it
needed to be prosecuted
and they would conduct that function but
the assessing certification board
would hear the case and make a decision
yes representative fellows this sets up
a complete professional board with
disciplinary with with certification
powers approval of continuing education
and discipline of the licensees the old
plc is merely the administrator
representative
thank you madam chair so
my understanding
of this bill is that you wish to
put this into statute with oplc because
existing
requirements for assessors are not being
upheld what is the the root of the
problem in you know in english okay
so right now if an assessor
has a complaint against them and it's
determined to be founded meaning it's a
legitimate complaint
and discipline occurs
no one knows about that
it's it's not that information is not
available to the public
that's a problem because the public
should be aware of
whether someone's got an issue with with
assessing
um
as a as an assessor
i find it's an issue because
if someone's
conducting themselves in a fashion
that got them in trouble it would be
nice to know
what you know what the result of that
was what what the actions were that got
them in trouble and what the result was
so that
you know we we make make we're more
careful about how we conduct ourselves
but if we don't know that
you know it's possible that we step in
the same landmine
and and aren't aware of it so it really
needs to be open and
realist if a real estate appraiser has a
complaint against them that whole
process is open you can go onto the new
hampshire real estate appraisal board
site
and look anybody up to find out if
they've ever had any discipline going
back
30 years and it's all public
and that's how this should be as well
follow up
yes thank you
and does this also apply to
okay let me let me back up is if a town
hires an a uncertified assessor is that
against the law
depends on what they're hiring them to
do
they
you know it
if you hire someone
to do particular services
they need to be certified and qualified
to provide those services whether it's
an employee whether it's robert gagne
working for the city of manchester i
need to be certified
at the level of work i'm doing as a as
my responsibility and it goes right down
to someone that's visiting a property
just to gather information whether it's
an employee or a contractor that
individual needs to be certified at the
level of doing their work
thank you
all right thank you other representative
o'brien and then shewett
thank you for taking my question i
understand what you're doing here and
i'm all about the transparency but
i would imagine in your line of work
that you're always going to have people
to disagree with their particular
assessment
so
i'm concerned about the assessor himself
or herself
what is the safeguard here
with this if uh
you know what would be to claim you know
if somebody was actually 100
doing their job where does that tally up
against that particular person
so so
that would be the the part of the work
that the oplc would do is if a complaint
is made
they would need to determine if there
was a violation of a rule or a law
so if someone wasn't happy with their
assessment and they complained that's
not a founded complaint there are other
avenues to take care of that and that's
not a violation of any rule or law
you know people people don't necessarily
like to pay taxes and they're unhappy
even if the even if the numbers are
correct
so that would not be a founded complaint
and that would not
you know
it's not going to be a public black mark
on somebody because that's never going
to make the public record if it's an
unfounded complaint
and and that would be the same whether
it stayed at the dra and the records
were opened
or whether it was set up with the oplc
thank you sir
representative
thank you madam chair
mr gangney i'm
trying quickly on my tablet to find
the membership of the assessing
standards board
are there public members of that board
yes the current makeup is
there there are so
it's
two reps two state senators
the commissioner of the department of
revenue or their designee
there are four assessing seats
there are
three municipal representatives and
two or three members of the public
there's 15 members all together
follow-up
and have you encountered
any difficulties in getting
members
to meetings and so forth we've heard
testimony from
oplc in recent weeks about
difficulty of getting members
for quorums for meetings and so forth
and particularly public members so i'm a
little concerned about the number of
public members proposed for this board
so we do have a couple of open seats
right now we've only had one public seat
open for a prolonged period of time like
three or four years i believe
it hasn't been an issue with with making
quorum at this point
but i believe there are two more seats
they can right now and it could become
an issue
and i don't know if it's a matter of
people not willing to serve or
um
the processing not not taking place yet
i can tell you that the four assessor
seats
we were up for renewal this year um last
year september of 21 and
the the
it's the new hampshire association of
assessing officials that puts those
names forward before the governor
executive council
and we have not received any indication
that the council has heard
um our
you know and we we serve until we're
replaced so the four of us is still
serving but but we expired in september
and that hasn't been filled yet so
that's a processing it's you know there
are four
names they are ready to go
but they haven't been processed yet
representative seitan
mr cagney you said something uh this
this mirrors the real estate board and
that you it's public information you
could go back 30 years to find
this behavior you think that
somehow i'm uncomfortable with somebody
record for 30 years would you have that
in mind for accessory too
their record would not clear after a
certain
uh certain period of time seven years
i i don't believe there isn't any
clearance on that board certainly if
if if it was the intent of the lawmakers
to have some such provision
um
i guess i'd have to think about what
that period of time would be
um
and then it also would be you know if
you have another infraction it seems to
me that that information ought to stay
no matter how far back it goes
so
thank you are there any other questions
representative broda
thank you so in in some
i
are you asking then in the statute to
move the board
from under the supervision of the dra
to
the oplc
so the assessing standards board would
continue
as it exists today
this would set up
another board an assessing certification
board that would be under the oplc but
the assessing standards board would
still be administratively tied to the
department of revenue
thank you other questions
representative fellow
thank you
i
tell me what i'm not understanding here
because for me it seems to me that the
board that creates the standards
would be the best group of people to
judge if somebody's violated those
standards
that's a good question now
the the
the qualifications to be an assessor
would fall under the new assessing
certification board
the education the experience and so
forth i would see those rules
of the asb moving over
but there are
assessing standards that apply to
not just individuals but to
jurisdictions
you know cities and towns need to have
values anew every five years
they need to be done under certain
standards meaning when you do a
revaluation your results need to be
within certain uh statistical tests
that's separate from certifying the
individuals do the work
those are requirements on
boards of assessors boards of selectmen
other other governing bodies so
you know while while everything that
falls under the assessing standards
board purview now
isn't going to stay there
you know certification
rules
and disciplinary rules are going to move
over to that new board but the standards
under which assessing is conducted
you know that that you review your
records that your values fall within
certain ranges
those would stay on the assessing
standards board side
follow-up
so it's possible i'm starting to get a
hold of this so the existing board now
which is the assessing standards board
is that really
focused more on what municipalities are
doing and you're because you're telling
me you know they have to do the
reassessment every five years and not so
much on the people who are doing it
the qual the qualified people who are
doing the assessment
so so today it's both
both what you know what work the
municipalities do and also the
qualifications of the individual what
we're proposing is that
the qualifications the certification of
the individuals be moved over to that
independent board
and the other duties
stay with the assessing standards board
thank you very much
other questions
all right i'd like thank you for your
testimony i did just have one other a
couple of notes that i had that i i
didn't address yet if i could
oh if i could do a follow-up
yes follow-up so um one of the things i
wanted to mention um
in talking with my peers is that
um
we kind of view sometimes that there
might be a conflict of interest with the
way it's set up today with the
department of revenue
um and we feel this would take that out
entirely
between the department of revenue their
employees and
the assessing individuals out there that
are certified
thank you very much thank you uh carolyn
learn
good morning carolyn lear i'm the
assistant commissioner at the department
of revenue
i'm honestly really here at your
pleasure for your questions if you have
them
but i would take a second of liberty
just to emphasize
that
assessors play a hugely
important role
in administering the state property tax
certainly from the state's perspective
the state has a direct interest
in ensuring that those who perform the
assessments for purposes of property
taxes
are qualified to do that role very
specifically with respect to the 363
million dollars in swept that gets
assessed every year
but also with respect to the over four
billion dollars of local property taxes
that get assessed each year
property taxes are by far the largest
revenue stream in the state
the next being the business tax which is
only a billion and only hit the billion
mark within the last year
so i would just encourage you as you are
considering this policy decision
um
to think about just how important the
role of assessor certification is
otherwise the only other note i would
make and mr gagne
did refer to it briefly there is another
bill coming from the senate
senate bill 53
is a more exacting
attempt to make
the assessor certification records
public
as some of you may have encountered the
department of revenue has a pretty broad
confidentiality statute
that makes pretty much everything that
the department does confidential absent
an exception and senate bill 53
would make
an exception to our broad
confidentiality statute
relative to assessor certification
records and
if that were to pass we would have no
problem sharing those records freely
it's really a statutory issue currently
that prevents us from sharing both
certification records as well as
disciplinary records
with that i'm happy to answer any of the
committee's questions
thank you i take it the department is
not opposed to losing the
to creating a new board about assessor
certification thank you for the question
um no the department does not take a
position on this legislation opposed or
in favor
all right thank you are there questions
from his learn
all right
of representative scitec
doesn't sp 53 take care of this
situation why do we even have um
this bill if sb 53 takes care of the
confidentiality the transparency issue
that mr gagne raised as the principal
mode of impetus for the bill
i'm not sure i could answer that
question
other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much
uh scott bartlett
i do have some written
testimony who should i give that to you
good morning thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak
my name is scott bartlett i am the
assessor for the town of goffstown
i'm not taking a position on this bill
one way or the other
um
if this is done properly i don't really
believe it it makes a difference to me
whether i am
being certified by the department of
revenue or a certification board
i do have some concerns
with the way this bill is written
my first and most major concern has to
do with transition
as i read the bill it does appear that
on january 1st 2023 if this bill were to
pass
no one in the state would be certified
i do do not believe there is time to
get this in place
in less than a year and have all the
certifications be
renewed
there's no grandfather clause in this
there's no
transition from
current
certification to the new certification
board
right now i am a certified new hampshire
supervisor or susser supervisor
my term runs out in 2024.
but if this bill were to pass i believe
that on january
or actually be december 31st
of the end of this year i would no
longer be certified
um
that's a concern
because i'm looking to protect my town
town of goffstown to make sure that on
january 1st of next year
i can continue to do my job
so i do it believe at the very least
there would need to be some type of a
grandfathering clause
some way to transition smoothly from
the dra to this new board
the other concern i have
is
with the definition of the three
assessor members on this board
it's very broad it has no limitations as
to who they should be
as i read it i believe you could have
three
dra employees
as the three assessors i don't believe
that would happen but the way the bill
is written that could happen
so i would
recommend that there be some
clarification as to who those members
should be
in my opinion you should have a city
assessor employed by a city a town
assessor employed by a town and maybe a
contracted assessor but again those are
just my suggestions and
for making this bill
a little bit better
the the third issue that i looked at was
the number of public members now it was
already mentioned here that there seems
to be a difficulty of getting public
members to attend meetings
i also was concerned about the number of
public members
i did look at a lot of the other boards
in the state of new hampshire and
remember this is a licensing a
professional licensing board
not a
standards board similar to what the
assessing standards board is
this is
deals with professionals and the vast
majority of the other boards in this
state
the professionals are the majority of
those boards that is not the case with
this particular board the other thing i
noticed that the public members in every
board i looked at
were less than
the professional members in this case
it's the same number
the one thing i
notice that's missing is other
professionals from different fields so i
would recommend
possibly considering a
certified appraiser certified with the
new hampshire real estate appraiser
board and maybe even a um
a real estate broker or agent
these are individuals who
are not assessors they don't understand
exactly what we do but they're very
similar fields and they would have a lot
of input and i think they would be a
great asset to this board
again as i said i'm not opposed to the
general idea of this
but i do believe this particular bill
needs some work thank you very much
thank you for your testimony will you
take questions
yes ma'am representative
thank you madam chair
thank you um i'm sorry i didn't catch
the last name i guess it's on your paper
yeah bartlett b-a-r-t l-e-t-t um are you
familiar with the senate bill that was
mentioned
i have heard of that as well i do
believe
i'll be honest with you i will support
that particular bill
thank you
other questions
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair uh mr bartlett
thank you for taking my question um
you said there will be a vacancy if this
bill becomes enacted from the start date
trying to look it up right now but uh
there'll be leeway nobody would be
certified how long is the certification
like as a gentleman as yourself to get
yourself up to speed if this bill was
enacted
um i'm not sure okay what i mean is you
said uh if this bill is enacted nobody
would be certified
okay you would have to get recertified
you know people would have to get
certification how long does that take
i'm not exactly sure how long it would
take because again this bill is kind of
vague as to how
that board is is created so
uh
a lot of it has to do with how quickly
the
positions get filled
i mean no one can be certified until
there's a board to start with so on
january 1st of next year has this board
already been created
will the governor have had time to put
those members in if not there's no one
there to
certify me
i mean typically the process with a
board that is up and going i am also a
certified
appraiser with a real estate appraiser
board
that process is very quick very
efficient but that board has been up and
running for a number of years so a year
from now or two years from now
i don't believe there'll be much delay
it's just that in that transition period
getting
the board created getting everybody on
board determining
what the qualifications are
that's not addressed here so i'm just
concerned with that one to two year
period of transitioning from one to the
other
follow-up follow-up okay what datton
stated in looking at and i have yet to
see it but looking at senate bill 53
debt is addressed in that senate bill
then well the senate bill is is
different in that it's changing the
um
confidentiality
of the dra has nothing to do with
creating a
a licensing board
there would be no issue there because
we're not in that case if that bill were
passed and this one we're not
in that case
we wouldn't have to transition because
we would still be certified through the
dri very good thank you for the
clarification thank you representative
marsh uh thank you madam sharon thank
you for taking my question i don't know
if you have a copy of the bill in front
of you if you don't
you might need to get one
my question is would your concerns about
the transition period be adequately
addressed if we just changed the
effective date of section 5 of the bill
which is when
the certification changes to the new
board
to an effective date two years hence
and that way the board can be set up and
everybody will know when the new board
will take effect and we can continue to
operate under the old board in the
meantime
i do believe that would
take care of a lot of the concerns
thank you
representative fellows
thank you can you just tell us about
what the qualifications are you know i
don't need too technical the
qualifications to be an assessor okay
well first of all there's a number of
different categories i am a assessor
supervisor which is the highest
category of certification for an
assessor in order to be a supervisor i
need five years of experience in
assessing
i need
i don't know the exact hours but i
believe it's around 300 hours of
education
i need to there's a couple of other
i need to have worked on a revaluation
i need to have testified in court
for assessing purposes
the qualifications are fairly extensive
it isn't something that
someone can come off the street and be
an assessor tomorrow it takes it takes
time
the lowest level of certification is a
measure and lister
that i believe is
i think 160 hours of of being supervised
thank you
um
and then there's different levels
there's an assessor super our assessor
trainee
and then there's an assessor and then
the final step would be a supervisor so
each step has
education
requirements has experience requirements
something that has just been initiated
to be a supervisor you now have to pass
a test
many of us that are assessor supervisors
are also certified new hampshire
assessors
which
we've already taken a test i took a test
in order to become a cnha certified new
hampshire assessor
again that's another question i have
with farm is for the transition do i
have to take that test again
if i have to i will
but these are some of the questions that
i have
represented pearson thank you thank you
mr bartlett for coming up from goffstown
for this
as the chairman of the subcommittee on
uh
licensing we we look at all kinds of
things that need little tweaks and
twists to work i'm wearing a pen out
right now
okay so
if this was to go to interim study and
we actually took took a look at this
more in the off season so to speak
would that be something you'd be willing
to contribute to to help
assist with the the clear the clearly
clearly gaps that that have existed
in just your you know your that you've
brought up in your testimony so far
yes sir most definitely
thank you representative marsh
madam chair you already took my question
i'm fine
any other questions
representative
so i just took a quick look at senate
bill 53
and senate bill bill 53 seems to address
the conflict of interest of
confidentiality of the drv through
statute
as opposed to creating a board to do
that
do you
would that be a
correct understanding
again i didn't
i wasn't part of writing of of either of
these bills
my understanding of it it does address
the confidentiality
issue i do believe there is not the only
issue i believe that
one of the other concerns that people
have had about the dra
being the licensing board or the
certification board is that they're also
certifying their own employees
that would that particular bill would
not
take care of that issue
thank you madam chair but you did say
you would support senate bill 53 and you
have no position on this one
that is correct
last question so i'm trying to
understand why that is
well
personally i have no issue with the
department of revenue
it's a person more personal and you know
my opinion
i understand some of the issues that
others are bringing up
but to me whether i'm being certified by
the department of revenue administration
or licensing board
it's not going to impact me directly
therefore that's the reason i'm just
i'm neutral on this bill
thank you okay other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
lori archulana
lori ordolano um
i don't know if i'm the only citizen
speaking today as a citizen on this
issue
i live in nashua and i'm um providing
testimony in support of creating this
certification or this discipline and
certification board for
assessors
mr gagne
indicated that there was some citizen
support and
citizen concerns at addressing this and
i would be one of those citizens
new hampshire has a very high reliance
on property tax
to fund the government and these
assessors play a critical role
in creating fair and equitable
assessments
and all of this depends on transparency
when the department of revenue is the
agency that is providing the review
of these assessors and handling the
complaints
it presents a potential conflict of
interest
in the second issue you heard was that
these complaints were being maintained
confidentiality in confidentiality um
not released to the public and senate
bill 53 will take care of that and i'm
in full support of that
you know i'd like to speak to some of
the questions i heard raised here as a
citizen because i feel i'm more free to
speak to them
one
member asked you know could you give me
a candid reason why this is being done
and i think the candid reason is you
have the fox guarding the hen house here
when the dra serves as the agency for
oversight
alone without
assessors
they have assessors who work for them
under their control under their
leadership under their management
the formal complaint process for
bringing a complaint against an assessor
is called a pa 71 form can be filled out
by any citizen who wants to raise a
complaint to the dra regarding an
assessor most of them in a municipality
but if you raise that a complaint
against an internal assessor at the dra
now the dra has to look at the internal
assessors work that they were overseeing
and make a judgment on whether they were
in violation
chairman
gagne mentioned that there's a potential
conflict of interest here i agree
by setting up the oplc board
and setting it up to have citizens
assessors and a rep and the commissioner
of the dra or a designee you have a more
balanced board
one gentleman
mr bartlett who just spoke mentioned he
was concerned about board balance
too many citizens
if i read the bill correctly one of
those citizens could have an assessing
background or have a background in
appraising
so as it stands now it's a seven-member
board four could be and would be
associated with some um or have
knowledge of assessing two of the
citizens may potentially not
i don't consider that too unbalanced
as it stands now the 15-member board of
the assessing standards board the asb
pretty large
i wouldn't want to keep it under that
board at that size because i think it's
too big a board i like consolidating it
down to a seven member board i think
it's more effective now as it stands now
there are only three citizens on that
15-member board one seat's been vacant
for three years maybe going on four
you know i myself and other people have
argued for a while that there are not
enough citizens
on that board that board was really set
up to be a more balanced board
overseeing and providing input on
certification of assessors
allowing the public to have a a a part
of it and and assessors as well and
municipalities and the public ended up
playing a pretty small role and right
now it's two public members to 14
committee members and i think the public
voice there is is too small
so um
so i think the balance in what's
proposed on this board is
is pretty good
um
i think by creating so i'm not certain
that i i think that this needs to stay
with the asb the asb can serves as an
arm of the dra
creating all of these regulations for
municipalities less focused on the
individual assessor when there is an
individual assessor issue it goes to the
dra
but the dra operates on their own
outside of any oversight at all
um
an interesting thing is the oplc handles
certification for appraisers there are a
number of
um
municipalities that have certified
appraisers
in their city government we have one in
nashua um
if you have an a
if i had a complaint against that
appraiser slash assessor and i filed
that complaint it would go to the oplc
if it was found justified it would be
released publicly so right now the
appraisers in municipalities will have
any disciplinary action that was
actually taken against them a part of
public record but those that are not
licensed
appraisers and are only certified
assessors
are allowed to maintain confidentiality
of those issues
and i am a person who filed pa-71s down
in nashua against several assessors
sanctions were found
and shockingly to me when i read the rsa
i thought
i'm just a citizen i thought they were
going to be public the dr the asb board
thought and believed at that time that
they were public nobody really realized
they weren't public until i had kind of
pushed the issue
and then
i learned that they couldn't be released
the dra sent me a nameless sheet
of all of the infractions they found
that had occurred
but they wouldn't identify who they were
applied to
i knew who i had submitted my pa 71s
against and i could track my claims
versus what was found
but i really didn't have a right to make
it a public record
i couldn't say that i discovered
anything and when those sanctions came
out our mayor of the city announced that
they were minuscule issues insignificant
and not important just brush them off as
some lady complaining about nothing
how dare she
so um i was so disappointed that two
years of work to try and validate that
things weren't right in an office got
swept under the rug by the municipality
um
that the items that uh mr bartlett
brought up i think they're reason you
know reasonable i would
i would say you know i would like this
not to be killed i'd like it to be
studied further if that's what it needs
and and tweaked as far as you know all
assessors becoming decertified instantly
well let's put a grandfather clause in
there you know this isn't rocket science
here we've started other
oversight groups that have been part of
the oplc and there's a startup mechanism
and let's make certain that language is
folded into our bill
um
and let's you know clarify the assessors
who are on that board to look at
complaints or certification that comes
forward
i think it's very important so
i very much support this and i support
it as a citizen
not tippy-toeing around the fact that
the dra has my certification and i have
to be careful about what i say but i
really think you have the fox guarding
the hen house here and you need to
broaden that a little bit
um and
representative o'brien here raised a
very very valid point you know people
complain all the time about assessors
how do we protect them we protect them
by only releasing information that is
actually a sanction
the ones that are not found valid should
nev will never be released it should not
so
thank you very much
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from the committee
okay this will be going to subcommittee
and i hope we will be able to do
something with it
thank you
jim michaud
uh good morning mr chair in light of the
prior testimony and your comments just
now i'm just going to provide my written
testimony thank you thank you very much
for your efficiency we will read your
testimony
okay
any does anyone else wish to testify on
house bill 1552
seeing none
i will close the public hearing and send
it to the subcommittee on licensing
and i'll open the public hearing on
whatever our next bill is
on house bill 314.
okay
okay representative
nunes how nice to see you you're going
to uh fill out a pink card after you've
done testifying i will i forgot to fill
out the pink card thank you madam chair
should i begin
please
madam chair members of the committee
it's so good to see all of you
i did send in a written testimony this
morning to everyone if you didn't get in
your email inbox yet um it will be there
and madam chair i can provide a hard
copy for the folder uh if i can approach
afterwards
madam chair committee members thank you
for hearing my presentation today for
house bill 314 as amended relative to
homestead food operation
licensure
excuse me
this bill is being presented as amended
by the health and human services
committee it was originally presented
last session
and was actually a much bigger bill than
this however it was retained and
thankfully assigned to a subcommittee
i worked with that subcommittee and
we came to an agreement to keep the most
important part of the bill through an
amendment this agreement was bipartisan
and unanimous in the subcommittee
in which the subcommittee brought the
amended bill to the committee it was
passed unanimously and placed on the
consent calendar and now we're here for
our second committee hearing
in the house
what we've done is we've narrowed this
bill down to
to allow an increase in the amount of
gross sales for homestead goods produced
by homesteaders from twenty thousand
dollars to thirty five thousand dollars
we felt that at this time
time meaning over the past few years
that
homesteaders have suffered greatly
particularly during the pandemic
when sales were stifled because of
farmer market shutdowns
and when farm stands were not visited by
customers due to either a coveted
restriction or safety needs our
homestead vendors lost out
goods that had been prepared for sale
were discarded
no new sales were achieved in numerous
cases
and now that we're rolling along in our
economy the price and expense
of these products that it takes for a
homestead vendor to even make their
goods at home
have now been inflated by 200 to 300
percent in some cases
that leaves the net profit much less
than ever before
many homestead kitchens
their sales are a great supplement to
the households
of these folks they depend on the sales
to add to their income the products they
sell are potentially non-hazardous goods
and are regulated by the department of
health and human services
nothing in this amended bill changes any
of that we're only changing the gross
sales amount
we would like to be able to give the
homestead community some coveted relief
or economic relief either way you want
to go with it
to help get them back to where they were
and to help to afford for them to afford
to create the products that they make
and still be able to make a meager
amount for those sales
i asked the committee to consider this
bill and vote for the auto pass as
amended so that we can
move this bill onto the next phase
with our friends from the other body
let's let's help our homesteaders i'm
more than willing to take any questions
well thank you i have a question do you
know at what date the twenty thousand
dollar exemption was put into law i do
not know madam chair uh thank you for
the question i do not know the exact
date but it was many years ago
and this this bill
of similar bills uh even for this amount
have come up several times in the past
and haven't been able to quite make it
through the process i'm hoping that
we'll understand that
prices go up and
and these folks need to be able to
adjust with the times
okay thank you
other questions
represent goalie
thank you madam chair i guess the
question is more to you as to
why is this bill before the committee
what are we reviewing
uh
actually i believe it came to us from
its original
incarnation as a major licensing issue
but
and i didn't catch it in time when it
passed the house that had been amended
such that it's
really not our bailiwick
thank you
and the fellow
thank you madam chair my my only
question has to do with
the food
i just want to get a sense of like
what's covered and not covered because
it says some foods are excluded because
they're potentially hazardous so i'm
thinking of the things i might see
at the farmer's market
uh representative fellows that's
that's the current law and the current
definitions
and
this bill does nothing to change it
and i believe the current the hazardous
materials are things like
hazardous food yeah well raw fish i
think are qualified
i don't know for sure
madam chair do you want me to to speak
to that
if you like briefly real real quickly um
there there is a difference hhs a
website has a list of the potentially
hazardous and non-hazardous foods there
i didn't include it in with this because
the bill is amendment amended no longer
talks about any of that we're only
talking about the gross sales amount
representative marsh and then shut
yes thank you madam chair i just wanted
to point out that food protection comes
under the baileywick of the hhs
committee and this was discussed quite
extensively in the prior hearing and
really doesn't come in our jurisdiction
so thank you for that
representative
thank you madam chair this is probably
more for you also
this seems to be now a matter since
health and human services
was the original committee uh it seems
more a matter of the amount involved
which seems like it should have gone to
ways and means is there some way we
could involve it is no it would not go
to ways and means
it's not a
this is a
raising the threshold
under which one is exempt from the
licensing requirement
it doesn't change what the licensing
requirement is it just says
under these this sales level you don't
have to to get licensed thank you so it
is sort of a licensing issue madam sure
that's exactly correct the the licensing
homesteaders are allowed to prepare from
a home kitchen as a home kitchen is set
up
licensing comes in when the production
of that food outgrows the home kitchen
and they have to buy commercial
um
you know
appliances and things to to produce to
produce that and then they need to be
inspected by hhs to make sure they're
following all the rules
and i know that the non-hazardous foods
includes things like apple pies and
cookies
correct if it has a if it has a cover
over the top of it you know no no no
nothing that can sit out in the in the
air and potentially get bacteria on it
representative o'brien ah thank you
madam chairman thank you representative
for taking the question uh
i understand what you're trying to do
tell me why you went with 35 000 from 20
000 uh is that negotiable or is do you
have a reason for that particular number
thank you representative for the
question uh we originally uh talked
about 50 000 but uh realize that a
seventy five percent increase on twenty
thousand even though through
inflationary measures would probably be
a more acceptable standard
other questions
okay seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you madam chair i'll
approach with the copies for the folder
is i don't have any cards
so is there any mem anyone else who
would wish to testify on house bill 314
all right seeing none i'll close the
public hearing on house bill 314.
yes
representative laccas
i suppose so
represent representative laccas would
like to go into executive session and
make some motion of
i think since it's already been amended
and passed the house it would be otp is
that correct
unless you have another amendment no no
my
motion is ought to pass representative
march seconds that
thank you so we have a motion by
representative lekkis
seconded by representative marsh would
you wish to speak to your motion
i think the discussion we just heard
covers it
representative marsh yes i just would
like to add that the statute was last
amended in 2014 and increasing the gross
sales amount of twenty thousand dollars
to thirty five thousand dollars
reflective of the increase in prices
particularly of food over the last seven
years is
both appropriate and
since i represent a very rural district
in new hampshire would be appreciated by
many of my constituents so thanks thank
you
is there anyone else who wishes to speak
on on the bill
all right
seeing none i will uh
actually say that that's eight years at
this point but
we'll we'll go with that
all right in that case the motion is
ought to pass by representative lackas
seconded by representative marsh is
there the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson
yes
representative jacobovich yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative juan zara yes
representative
yes
representative goalie
representative show it
yes
representative
were you in that was not in the room
representative marsh
votes yes
representative fellows yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
yes the chair
yes 16-0
okay
the vote being 16-0 the motion passes
without objection we'll put it on
consent
we are off until the next hearing at one
o'clock
and here's the pink card
and this
and this is from alanzar from the
subcommittee
john keeps all the papers
the papers
um
a coffee last week and i have a few
extra beers
sort of
speaking of which you and i are going to
get the
building code update
yeah okay
i'm sorry yeah
license
or say that anybody local option and
anybody who is licensed you have the
right to inspect their premises
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
it being one o'clock i will open the
hearing for house bill
relative to the state building code the
committee will recognize
chairman mcguire
thank you madam chair of members of the
of the committee i'm carol mcguire
representing merrimack 29 which is the
towns of allenstown epsilon pittsfield
and house bills 1681
is a recommendation
of the committee to study changes to the
state building code which
i had the honor to serve
so what it does is it updates
the building code to
the 2018 version from 2015
with the amendments adopted by the
building code review board which in most
cases are the amendments we made to the
building code just brought forward
like the elimination of the
sprinkler requirements for one and two
family homes and other issues that are
unique to new hampshire
i will there are a couple of other items
for example um
where are we at there
section
section four
says that if you apply for a building
permit
at the time the
the building code is changing
you can use either
the old or the new plan as long as you
tell
tell your
um whoever's granting your building
permit which version you're using
and you have to meet all the
requirements of that code so you can
either design your building for the
up-to-date more up-to-date version or
stick with the older one
your choice but you have to decide and
you have to say so
uh that was a request of the builders
who say that well you do we spend a lot
of time designing and working on it
and the building permit may not be
pulled
until just before you start construction
and so you wouldn't want to have to
go back and completely redo your plans
as a result of a code change when you're
90 of the way through
all right what else is there
section not 11 which starts on
line 17 on page 2
incorporates the
uh relaxation of the arc fault
requirements
that we adopted i think was three years
ago
and it it keeps
it keeps us from having unnecessary arc
fault
circuits that would trip unnecessarily
and to in many cases to
a great inconvenience to people that are
powering major medical devices on on
those circuits
but we approved that change
and so this just brings it forward
section six says that
local legislative changes to the
building code for their town
shall be
submitted to the state building code
review board for informational purposes
and the building code review board is
intending to keep
a
a database of which local amendments are
in place because it's extremely
difficult to find that out right now
okay
the uh section seven biomass burning
boilers and and log structures
just
incorporates into the building code
uh
some specific items that we had we have
approved in the past
what else there
okay and
sec section 8 which starts on 15 line 15
on page 3
requires the building code review board
to
review
a
a new version of the building code and
recommend adoption with amendments
for
for legislative approval approximately
every three years
the code
changes every three years
we fell almost 12 years behind
before we adopted the 15 and it was
a great difficulty for everybody
involved to keep up with it
so now that we're on the 15
this bill will move it up to the 18
schedule and in three years or so
they'll be reviewing the
codes with an eye to adoption and what
amendments we need
the reason to stay three years behind is
that
when the codes are first published there
are frequently
errors and vagueness
and omissions that need to be fixed so
we'll let the
more forward thinking in larger states
with bigger staffs
go through and find these issues and
then we'll uh we'll adopt them after a
couple of years
and what's that
that's about it the uh if you have
questions i'll try to answer them we've
got some real experts behind me that can
answer the technical questions
representative lucas
thank you madam chair um
is there
a document or list that kind of gives a
summary of the changes from the 2015 to
2018 building codes available
someplace
i know there is because they provided it
to the committee on updates i don't
i have a copy of it at home i didn't
bring it with me you can ask the
building code review board people for it
uh follow-up
actually another question
um
there's uh two sections on page three
line uh starting line four and line
twelve there's a
similar language that's struck out i'm
just
not clear to me what the effect is of
doing that
the it struck out because right now it
says they shall be
ratified by appropriate legislation if
that has been done already
n word and
this bill just incorporates it into the
previous approval that's on page one
okay thank you i i
before i go i have a
uh a confession it turns out that when
we drafted this bill and it was reviewed
by half a dozen people in the field
we neglected to include an update to the
state fire code
which had been intended and i'm working
working on an amendment to add it back
in
that was
everybody involved read the bill and
said yep that's good and didn't notice
the fire code hadn't been included so i
apologize abjectly and i will get the
amendment it so you can ask people about
it
everyone else here knows about that
omission and it was intended to be
included from the beginning we just
forgot to put it in writing
are there any further questions for the
representative
representative grota thank you
um representative mcguire i'm going back
to the
part of the bill that talks about a
period of overlap between the two
so
if someone were to say
that they're going to adopt the two
let's say it's 2000
let's say to now
and they're going to adopt the 2015
codes
i'm sorry representative groeder but
that's not possible
you can either adopt the the code as it
is approved
or you can adopt the newer version
but you can't go back to the 15 code
oh i see i see i see
so
how much long i mean what is the period
of all when you say a six month overlap
that means that if they use the previous
code
they've got six months to finish their
project
no
no they
building permits to be to be issued
thank you
representative pearson
thank you madam chair
it's a great opportunity when
representative mcguire is in the hot
seat here
in page two
when i'm
intimately familiar with your husband's
background page two here we're talking
about with the national electric code
there is seems to be no love for arc
fault circuit interrupters what what is
the um
what's the background as to why those
those are
specifically mentioned in
it's because in i believe it was the uh
the version after the 14 which would
probably be the 17
i think
at some point after the 14 code there
was a requirement for arc fault
interrupter circuits be installed
in many places in the house
the problem is
that in
most
electrical appliances are not entirely
compatible with arc fault circuits so
when your refrigerator turned on or your
dryer or whatever it would blow the
circuit
and
that caused a great deal of trouble for
people
if particularly if they got something
sensitive on the that's also on the
circuit
and so we passed a law saying you can't
that's not a requirement if you have
what details uh there are people here
who know them much more than i do
i just remember that it was specifically
approved in statute that you don't have
to
that you you could back off from the
requirement for our fault circuits all
over the place
are there any further questions
thank you representative mcguire
are there any members of the public that
wish to testify on this bill
if you or state agencies if you could oh
there we go there's our cards
right
the
the committee recognizes mr toomey
state fire marshall
good afternoon madam chair and members
of the committee
just be brief i just asked i shared
with
some written testimony to be passed
around
the the state fire marshal's office
supports the adoption of the 2018
building and fire codes i apologize for
us missing the fire code portion many of
us stakeholders have been part of this
over since through the summer and over
the last few years working to improve
the overall process uh
but i think we've we've got a good plan
in place to stay one code cycle behind
or three years uh
now and there's a great stakeholder
input work and many of them are behind
me today but
our office has been working with the
board of fire control on the
specifically on the fire code since for
the past two years
the board of fire control in my office
have been reviewing any proposed
amendments and looking at change
documents between the 15
15 edition of nfpa one which was the
uniform fire code in the 2015 edition of
the life safety code and comparing that
to what changes would be in place in the
2018 codes
we had multiple public hearings we
worked with the stakeholder groups
and uh had a hearing in january 27 2021
and out of that came to uh nine
amendments which are summarized on the
back of this document which we believe
should be moved forward as new hampshire
amendments for the new hampshire state
fire code
in summary there are many of them are
carry forward amendments that we've had
since
earlier editions of the code they're
currently in place in the 15 code
there's some new requirements that came
into play on the 2018 life safety code
and nfpa one relative to fall protection
uh we believe those are addressed well
in the ada and also the building code
and we didn't feel is necessary to also
have them in the life safety code and
the fire code because in some instances
it conflicted with already existing
codes
we adjusted some requirements around
sprinkler protection for the educational
occupancies to align better with the
building code
we adjusted some requirements on minimum
inspection frequencies for existing
occupancies
we have in place now requirements for
regular inspections for assembly
audiences and educational occupancies in
statute this if adopted would require
inspections for everything all
occupancies other than single-family
homes
on a regular basis based on risk and we
felt that that would make sense to have
that at the local level to decide what
the requirements are and we
suggested that language be changed from
a shell to a may so that the framework
was there but it could be addressed at
the local level if they
wanted to do that
we brought some carry forwarded
amendments and some adjustments to the
consumer fireworks stores
and also
provide some flexibility for minimum
professional qualifications for
inspectors plans examiners and fire
marshals or fire inspectors
the the way the language read in nfpa
one was that these would uh any of the
inspectors or any of the plans examiners
would require
certain professional qualifications that
would be mandatory in order them for to
do their jobs well we think that's a
wonderful
move forward to advance the trades uh in
the the profession but uh it's for
especially for the smaller departments
it's very difficult to get attain those
uh so we wanted to have that language in
there but not make it mandatory at this
point in time so sort of a summary of
where we're at with the petitions uh in
general on the on the back to the
building code side we've been uh we have
been part of those conversations and
we've been president at the board of the
building code review board i'll let the
people behind me speak more specifically
to that but we do support the
advancement of both the building and the
fire codes to 2018 edition thank you
no questions
thank you very much
mr rancourt
we shuffled
there we go
good afternoon uh madam chairman aboard
my name is stephen rancourt i'm a
licensed electrician in the state of new
hampshire and also the executive
director of the
ecba the electrical contractors business
association
we're here to support this bill in part
the way it's written in the updating of
the codes we went through a long process
of looking through the 2020 nec
through the state building code
subcommittees and
trying to
amend it as necessary and
we we think that this should clear up
any issues and go forward the one
concern that you had when you talked
about the ark faults was that
originally it was put in we addressed
the issue at the time it was the 2017
code that was being addressed
obviously as we've seen in a lot of
legislature now we try to clean up the
code so it doesn't have to come back
every cycle to be fixed this would
correct that issue
a lot of arc faults and i'm sure a lot
of people here remember don't want to
get back into it but there's a long
history in it causing a lot of issues
and this was just expanding it beyond a
level that was already there so
this this would just simply make it
consistent with that prior to 2017 going
forward until they can get some more
data and as an organization as an
electrician we support this bill going
forward
no questions
representative pearson
thank you and thank you mr court for
taking my question
um
i'm a former technical advisor for the
nfpa
so i'll i'll just ask you this with your
organization's issues with the
specifically this part of the standard
are you involved in the process to amend
or or bring forward to the nfpa
committee the concerns in reference to
that
because if we're bringing
this concern of another cycle forward
right this this can't be unique to new
hampshire the industry is gonna i would
presume is dealing with this in other
avenues so for the nec not to not to
take action or to modify it
how am i to think that something unique
is happening in new hampshire that's not
necessarily happening in frequency
enough to modify the code between
editions
um well with all due respect i would say
that it is happening across the country
and if you look you'll see what model
codes have been adopted across the state
i think there's only and i'm not exactly
sure like six or 12 that have adopted
the 2020 so far out of 50 states
and a lot of them still stay backwards
on the arc faults the problem that
happens and we we're okay with the arc
fault technology so to speak but they
don't require the manufacturers to make
the products work with the arc faults so
the i'm familiar with the the co-making
process with the nfpa and it's very
difficult to get that information in the
everyday problems
solved sometimes
so that's why this amendment was put in
because literally the code says that we
have to put in for manufacturer's
instructions and i can give you a copy
of a manufacturer instruction that says
don't put it on ockfall to ground fault
so that's just one example
people buy expensive
microwaves and dishwashers and stoves
refrigerators and the subzero
refrigerators don't work on the oc
faults but yeah we have to put them in
there's no standard to be honest with
you the problem is there's no standard
for rock faults if there was and then
every manufacturer had to work to that
standard we wouldn't have this issue but
every manufacturer can make their own
version of an arc fault
so it's across the board and when people
call you up and they say my my breaker
keeps tripping and i can't do anything
because the code requires to put it in
so this gives us some alleviate some of
the issues
remains into the bedrooms and places
like that locations that are
that are the most common for for fires
and don't usually have those appliances
per se in them that
helps
thank you that was extraordinarily well
done explanation thanks
see no further i think we'll be here
sorry representative o'brien
thank you madam chair
my question is along the oc fault line
uh
kind of helped me out a bit i think if i
was watering a house which i would never
do but anyways
uh
i grew up in a boston area where the
same plug that ran the refrigerator ran
the transistor radio in the front of the
apartment but the thing is today now
electrician will wire a separate
wire just for the refrigerator am i
correct or the microwave in the
appliance and they may not have to be
protected by opponent is that correct
correct the uh they'll run a separate
circuit to those higher parts and uh to
try to create that and the amount of
circuits that are put into a house
nowadays are a lot more than what they
used to be so it um that alleviates a
lot of the problem but being on that and
tripping if someone has a refrigerator
and it trips the arc fault and just
because of the refrigerator itself
nothing else really wrong with it
because of the frequency that with the
arc fault strip they lose everything in
the refrigerator in the middle of the
summer or something so
any other questions
see then thank you very much
mr sherman
oh my elastic gave up right at the right
time
my name is philip sherman i'm the chair
of the building code review board
madam chair and members of the committee
thank you for listening to me here i'm
speaking in favor of this bill
it's important that this bill be passed
in order to adopt the various 2018
international code council codes as well
as a 2020 national electric code and as
well to ratify the various new hampshire
amendments which have been approved by
the bcrb
this bill helps keep new hampshire
consistent with the desire to adopt
model codes that have been published for
two years and will ultimately help us to
get onto a standard three-year cycle
this bill corrects some language as
you've heard
regarding all arc fault circuit
interrupters it cleans up some language
regarding the current vcrb review and
approval process which requires an
amendment to await ratification by the
legislature prior to becoming effective
both hb 1681 and sb 398 provide for a
six month grace period
where the current code or the updated
code may be used the two bills used
slightly different language to
accomplish the same end and we recommend
that the language in hb 1681 be used and
i've submitted a comment to the senate
committee on sb 398 to that effect
further the bill provides a six-month
grace period where the current of the
updated code may be used at the
discretion of the applicant
a point has been raised by one of our
members that with the 60-day delay
in the effective date of this bill
followed by the six-month grace period
it starts to look more like an eight
month
grace period
given the fact that we're offering the
grace period and to maintain the maximum
flexibility for the users of the code
there may not be a need to delay the
effective late of the
effective date of this this bill for the
full 60 days there may be some minimum
period that's necessary for for other
purposes
there's also some overlap between hb
1681 and sb 433
regarding the posting of municipal
amendments
this bill maintains the current
requirement that the bcrb post municipal
amendments which are forwarded to us
only for informational purposes and adds
the provision that we do so only after
the municipality tells us about it
sb443 requires that the bcrb confirm
municipal appendments prior to adoption
by the local jurisdiction
and our proposed changes to sb 443
will coordinate that requirement with
the requirement to post
we simply
would ask that if sb 443 not move
forward or not be passed that we not
lose the language that's currently in
this bill which simply protects us from
the need to post something that we don't
know about
in conclusion we support this bill as
written but suggest a quicker effective
date i'll submit these comments in
writing and happy to respond to any
questions
representative
thank you um
so same question i asked chair mcguire
and that is is there a summary of the
changes between
the current code and the code we're
being asked to approve here
so our
our board uses a series of committees
for each code
and all of their work is posted on our
website
each committee submitted a short report
usually a page or two long
essentially summarizing their work
comparing the changes those also are on
the website
all of the exhibits which are an exhibit
for each amendment that's being proposed
are likewise posted within that work
so there is not one
complete summary but there is a summary
by by code for the seven codes or
eight codes we're talking about here
follow-up
can you please send an email to the
committee uh pointing to those happy too
thank you
seeing no further questions we thank you
for your testimony thank you
mr mckinney
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee my name is william
mckinney i'm the president of the new
hampshire building officials association
the
new hampshire building officials
association represents over 200 code
officials in the state contractors and
licensed design professionals who are
all involved with the state building
code
new hampshire building officials
association supports the adoption of
the
house bill 1681
and moving forward to the 2018 codes
it's very important as a code official
and for the state of new hampshire and
our municipalities that new hampshire
moves forward with getting onto a
three-year code cycle adoption
there's lots of there's lots of
technologies and advancements in the
construction industry that the codes
keep up with and if we don't keep up
with the codes we fall behind
also with by keeping up with the codes
you also help those communities stay up
to date with their um iso ratings if
you're familiar with that that's a
rating for the insurance industry that
helps to set the rates for property
insurances by the by the state falling
falling behind in the building codes the
communities are affected and it also
affects those communities it can affect
those communities for the insurance
rates
two cur two concerns were brought up
today um by other members here um
the first is the um six month delay
we support the six-month delay but we do
have a concern with as the bill is
written with the 60 day
after passage that would essentially
make it an eighth month delay as it's
written right now so we do support the
six-month delay that allows
contractors license design professionals
to work either on either the new code or
the code existing
for that period while they finish up
their projects
and again we also do support
inclusion of the new hampshire fire code
in this bill that's an important piece
to make sure that the building codes and
the fire codes move forward together for
new hampshire
and with that i will entertain any
questions
representative scitec mr mckinney would
you say your goal be accomplished if we
draft an amendment to this to make the
delays four months plus 60 days after
uh passage if that you'll still get your
six months
correct that
that i would leave that up to the
committee but yes that would work fine
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
mr pollock
there we go
you were just about to tell me
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee i'm ari pollock i'm an
attorney at the gallagher firm in
concord i'm here today as a lobbyist for
the new hampshire homebuilders we do
support the bill
we also support the amendment that the
fire marshal's office has discussed
relating to the inclusion of the
2018 nfpa codes for new hampshire
the home builders for a long period of
time have been a stakeholder at both the
building code review board and the fire
control board and have worked on what
has been described today as the carry
forward amendments so that compromises
that were baked into the 2015 version of
the code are now coming forward as
amendments baked into the 2018 version
of the code so that if this bill passes
as introduced it would not only
recognize an amendment to the definition
of the state code moving the 2015
versions to 2018 but it would bring
forward those amendments that modify
some of the language for its use in new
hampshire we think those compromises are
important and it's the basis of our
support for the bill and for the change
from the 2015 to the 2018 codes we also
recognize the importance of what's been
called the
grace period or
in the bill the concurrency period
we think that's an important measure to
provide some protection to
project designers architects project
owners general contractors who have been
relying upon a certain version of the
code and creating their project maybe
there's reason to move forward in the
code give them that election but also
give them the protection of that
concurrency period to stick with what
they've been designing under not knowing
fully whether or not another version of
the code would come in at a particular
time
otherwise let me just conclude by saying
that i've been doing this long enough to
have seen the opposite process where the
stakeholders don't work well together
the process becomes rather broken down
and unpleasant
and it's the opposite of what you're
being presented with today and there's
quite a bit of credit to go around for
um the the kumbaya you're seeing with
everyone testifying in support of the
bill and uh and and no big mob in the
back that's making angry faces at me um
it's a it's really a well maybe they are
i can't see and i don't dare turn around
um
i'll uh i'll hope for the best but um
let me just say that there are there
have been a core group of legislators
that have really championed this cause
chairman mcguire leading that pack of
course
senator carson on the senate side and
others
but also the stakeholders that are in
the room today and of course folks from
the department of safety
and the fire marshal's office so happy
to be part of the chorus and uh support
the bill thanks very much
and there any questions
seeing none
thank you for engaging in the humorous
banter
mr mckinney oh that's what i just had
we've already done mckinney
well is there another one
so i'm not exactly sure what this last
name is but is there a gentleman by the
name of chris that would like to testify
yes thank you madam chair and members of
the committee uh yes my wife was hoping
to meet a man named smith but
unfortunately she married a man named mr
scoglund
i am the director of energy transition
with clean energy new hampshire
um i'm not going to take up too much of
your time uh and just echo much of what
mr pollock said about really
appreciating the work that's gone into
this and being in general support of the
bill
clean energy new hampshire is a
non-profit member-based organization we
are new hampshire's leading clean energy
advocate that's dedicated to supporting
policies and programs that strengthen
our state's economy
by encouraging a transition to renewable
energy and promoting energy efficiency
and we're particularly uh
in support of the energy components that
are within this bill it would update
us from the 2015
international energy conservation code
to the 2018 code but with very little in
the way of amendments that would reduce
the efficiency of new buildings or
significant renovations
in light of this winter which has been
actually the as cold as winters had been
uh in the past um and with the higher
energy bills we're seeing because of
changes in the global energy market and
the draw of natural gas to other places
which have driven up prices overall
continuous improvement in our energy
efficiency will insulate new hampshire
homeowners
renters and businesses from any further
changes or rises in energy costs while
also protecting them from energy costs
during the summers which have been
warm and increasing in the
cooling demand
so in general we're in support of seeing
the energy code included
in previous editions it has been an area
of concern for many of the stakeholders
but through the work of
chairman mcguire and senator
carson as well as the stakeholders
behind us we've been able to reach a
process where
we have found agreement on how to move
forward on this code
in addition to all the others in
sync
thank you
does anybody have any questions nope
seeing none thank you very much
are there any other members from the
public that wish to testify on house
bill 1681
seeing none we will close the hearing
here we go
we will now open the
hearing for house bill 1191 the
committee recognizes representative
mcguire
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire merrimack
district 29 which is allenstown epsilon
pittsfield
and house bill 191 was put in at the
request of a friend
who had just bought a duplex and was
renovating it as his primary residence
and as a retired electrician he was
going to do most of the electrical work
himself
until he found out that he could not get
a building permit to do that work
because he was no longer licensed he's
retired
and it was a two family and therefore
the homeowner's exemption does not apply
so
that seemed a little much so i
put this in to
exempt the
two lines of work that homeowners can do
around their house that is mechanical
and
electrical
and expanded it to a single structure
to family home as well as a one family
one concern that we had
when we were talking about it is that
the codes required him to turn his two
two-family home into a one-family home
thereby destroying
a
[Music]
a necessary
dwelling unit which is a concern he was
also hoping to rent the other side of
the duplex
and the and then we have recently
required towns to allow accessory
dwelling units to be built
so that if for example
your sectioning off a part of your home
for a caretaker or your grandparents or
your grandchildren or whomever
you have to hire a licensed plumber and
a licensed electrician to do to do the
work even though you could
before you divide subdivided you could
do it yourself
so
that seemed incongruous to me so i'm i'm
hoping to
to bring this to the attention of
a lot of people
to see if this is exactly is actually
what we want to do regarding exemptions
the other thing is when i was looking at
the homeowner's exemptions i discovered
the
electrical code is pretty clear about it
plumbing code in its penalties for
plumbing without a
license does not mention the exemptions
that are in statute like
being a
a
school of of plumbing or a homeowner in
your own building whatever
so i changed
the penalties to
explicitly recognize the exemptions
and i will answer questions as i can i
believe there are some real experts
behind me
representative mcguire if i if i may ask
um
a question real fast so
i recognize the
you know the homeowner living in one
side of let's say it's a duplex and then
wanting to run out the other side so is
there was there any discussion when this
bill was being drafted what i'm going to
call a loophole as the person lives in
the one side
does the work on both sides and then a
year later moves to florida
well since the
personal working does not exempt anyone
from the requirements
for inspection of plumbing or electrical
work
i
there was not any that was mentioned and
we said well that's a rare occurrence
if we're getting the work done to code
which is one of the requirements and it
properly inspected then we don't think
there's an issue with it
thank you
representative marsh
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question my question regards
the language on line 6 and line 17 where
it's provided the person owns the entire
structure um
how does that interact with the fact
that most people buy their houses using
a mortgage and therefore may not
actually own the structure uh in
entirety at a certain point in time ah
well i think you're considered
you have a debt but you own the you're
considered the owner even if you have a
mortgage
and the point was raised that in
some cases of duplexes they are separate
deeds and one person can own one side
and a different person can own the other
side and
some of the people i talked to were
concerned that
the other owner might not be willing to
have an unlicensed person working on
their house on
on the house that they shared a wall
with say
thank you for the clarification
representative fellows
thank you um my question is just about
you mentioned something about like an
ancillary structure on the property so
um you could have a situation where
somebody owns a home and they live in
the house but the garage is separate and
there's an apartment in the garage and
when i read this
i would not think that the garage and
the house are the same structure so
is it your intent that it applies to the
garage department or not as written it
wouldn't because it's a because
unless the person was renovating the
garage for an apartment with the
intention of moving into the garage
and giving their you know let their kids
have the house but in general if you're
if you're cr if you have a stand-alone
accessory dwelling unit it would not be
considered
pearson
thank you
madam chair
representative mcguire just just so i'm
understanding what
was previously asked here in the in the
sense of a duplex that is
owned because it is an entire structure
that is owned by someone else on the
other side
under the law would that be viewed upon
for this purpose as no a single family
it would know no it specifically says
that the person
owns the entire structure
so if you have a duplex and i get the
definition of structure believe me but
it's it's just that sometimes the words
that we apply definitions to words that
in
the law don't necessarily mean what they
think they mean and that's my purpose of
clarification no it's that the intent
would be that if you have a
a duplex that is owned by
a single structure duplex owned by two
two entities
this exemption would not apply
thank you
and i have a second follow-up thank you
it's not really a follow-up second line
of questioning
the accessory dwelling unit
which has become a
and is gaining popularity here
doesn't it that
because i'm not familiar with the how
accessory drilling units are classified
tonight this may be for you or not but
does that now
count as a two family or is does that
specifically
maintain its status as a single family
residence with the inclusion of an
accessory dwelling in law apartment i'm
sure that there are details of it that
i'm not familiar with but my
understanding is that you are creating a
separate dwelling unit within your house
you're converting your house from a one
family to a two family
by creep putting in an adu
and if i'm wrong then that eliminates
some of the need for this bill but
i'm not getting any head nods behind you
in either direction so i i think we will
ask other people if they know to please
speak up on this i i am not an expert
representative bailey
thank you madam
um many of your examples featured
electrical examples
and yet
electrical's not in here it's all
plumbing
electrical is section three
starting on line 14.
i see yes thank you but yes there's
[Music]
it applies to plumbing as well just that
my friend who started this was a retired
electrician
are there any further questions from any
of the members
thank you representative mcguire
mr evans
thank you for allowing me to speak my
name is ted evans i'm a resident of
concord new hampshire
and i've spent a good part of the last
40 years of my career in building safety
i've been a building inspector i've been
a plumbing inspector
i've been a contractor and
i actually came to new hampshire 50
years ago with the dream of building my
own house and being able to do all the
work associated with that house
so i'm a firm believer in
you know new hampshire's
well-established right for homeowners to
do their own work in their own
single-family
detached
stand-alone structure
but i think that if
we have to understand that people are
permitted by law
under certain exemptions but they must
comply with the code
the law doesn't say they have to get
inspections
the code says we have to get inspections
but the code is not enforced in every
community in new hampshire we have to
remember that
that we have maybe 60 70 percent
coverage in new hampshire as far as
permits and inspections for this kind of
work
and a good part of new hampshire has
none
so when we allow people to do their own
work
and we assume they're going to follow
the code we really have no way to verify
that 100 of the time
my thinking is if we're going to expand
this exemption which has some merit
although i disagree and i think you'll
find a lot of people behind me opposed
to this idea
simply because it's not safe
and if we allow this to happen in two
family homes we're going to essentially
double the risk
without any increase in inspection
performance or inspection
responsibilities by these exempt
people
and it's not just electricians putting a
few receptacles in
it's not just plumbing putting a sink or
a toilet in
and it's not just gas fitting putting
boilers in that are fired by gas and
emit dangerous carbon monoxide gases if
not done properly so there's a lot of
risk
and the only way i can see justifying
adding to this risk by ex by expanding
exemption is by is by making sure that
people get their work inspected
and that it's bound to be compliant with
the code
that's the most important thing for
building safety and people safety
so how do we do that when we don't have
coverage for municipal inspections
i think the law could state something to
the effect that
anyone exempt under these
laws would require an inspection either
by a municipal inspector or by some
third-party inspector
and put that responsibility on the one
who's exempt from the code
to verify that they have followed the
code and that they've been inspected to
to verify that
i think without that we're really
opening the doors to a wild west
situation even worse than we have now
and trust me i've seen many situations
where homeowners got themselves into
trouble
with carbon monoxide exposures
with faulty plumbing with backflow
prevention you know backflow is
contaminated water coming into the
drinking water supply
so there's just too many dangers out
there
to um ignore
and i do think
while we're at it if we're going to
amend the exemptions we ought to make
them consistent from electrical plumbing
and gas fitting there's no reason why
the exemptions
should be unclear
which some of them are and different
depending on what trade you're in
so i think this bill needs a lot of work
i don't want to say i'm opposed to it
except that i'm opposed to it as written
the concept could work if we had a
better level of safety
and verification to answer any questions
representative scitec
i've just learned something from you and
that's that you're telling me sixty
percent of the state or somebody will
come in and do the work according
supposedly according to the code and
it's not inspected
is that right
well i may have thrown out a number i
don't know that 60 percent i was saying
60 is probably we are covered with
inspections but maybe 40 percent is done
without inspections
well whether you like excuse me whether
you're licensed or not if you're not
inspected
i have trouble with that
the license doesn't mean anything the
inspection means something to me but i'm
not testifying so thanks
representative bailey
thank you
i made a mistake earlier in overlooking
the electrical at the bottom
i
draw your attention to lines eight and
nine where they must use the applicable
code application and inspection
requirements wouldn't they have to have
it inspected under that there are many
towns excuse me but there are many towns
in new hampshire that have no code
enforcement whatsoever
so how do they get those inspections
yeah with or without a licensed
electrician yeah
thank you
representative o'brien
you stimulated my mind representative
hill with that
particular question but
would it be true sir
if uh something went awry even though
there's no building instructor uh
inspector in that particular community
and something went awry that
particular provider if he's licensed
could risk losing his license if he
wired or plumbed in something
not by the current code accepted by the
state correct
someone's license could be at risk if
they did not follow the code correct
any further questions from the members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very much
mr trombley
button sorry
all right good afternoon madam chair my
name is bill trombley i'm a
owner of a plumbing bill tromby plumbing
heating in manchester new hampshire
i served on the mechanical board for
many many years just getting off of it
this last
december
i'm also part of the
plumbers and fuel gas association that
represents about 300 licensees in the
gas and plumbing industry
and as i put down on my my slip
that i'm representing myself but i'm
also representing the gas
association where as
this bill is written
as it's written right now the
association is opposed to this to this
bill
um in general um
expanding the ex the exemption for
plumbing into in the gas is is extremely
dangerous in our opinion
we're currently dealing with a lot of
it seems like
in the last year or so there's a lot of
house flippers
and we're seeing a lot of
systems and plumbing in on the gas that
we're technically installed by code
some of them were installed by code some
of them weren't some of them were
inspected some were not inspections you
got to remember
permit inspection is a is a local issue
not a state issue
um it would be nice if we could
strengthen up
requiring a
inspection by the state
if this
the way it's written right now if this
bill was designed
for the accessory housing this opens it
up to one and two families not just the
accessory housing so we if it's going to
be meant for the accessory housing
then we would like to
i think hopefully somebody will be
offering an amendment today to amend it
to
have it for the accessory housing
and
not to be in a rental situation
we understand that the new hampshire way
if we want to build our own houses we
want to be able to build our our own
houses
um and we're not opposed to that um
but
we just need to make sure that we're
protecting the citizens out there
we don't want to see the
the
you know the landlords buying two family
houses not just duplexes two family
houses
and the way this is written
it opens it up to the two family houses
in in manchester we have a lot of
two family houses that
if the owner is
owns it
um
they can do their own plumbing and gas
fitting we don't want to see that
representative o'brien
ah thank you madam chair and thank you
sir for taking my question mr toomey
in all
regards within this bill plumbing do you
think the plumbing would include
anything that is currently large as far
as septic systems is that would not be
considered like plumbing
such as a homeowner replace an
acceptance system not uh crushing the uh
the existing tank if he made a
changeover or whatever
so in new hampshire our plumbing law
ends about
10 feet outside the foundation
so the septic system does not fall under
the plumbing code that's under des
and just to answer one of your other
questions if a plumber or gas further
does do something that's against code
they they are opening themselves up to
either
sanctions on their license or
losing their license or it could be a
misdemeanor and if there's somebody that
gets hurt it could end up being a felony
representative grota
thank you um
mr trombley you had mentioned duplex and
you had mentioned two family homes so
could you tell me is a duplex a
two-family home or is that something
different
uh i don't i don't know the definitions
in law what's a duplex and what's a
two family a duplex to me
is there's one owner of one side and
another owner of the other side okay a
true family is um
you know one person owns the building
um and he rents out the either
one unit or two units
so
if it's written like here if one person
owns the whole structure
okay he can do the work in the one in
two family that he rents out to one or
two families and he doesn't live there
thank you
representative fellows
um i just wanted to explore the idea of
requiring an inspection
so in terms of the
plumbing and the gas
if somebody did the you know did the
changes made made changes on their own
if an inspector came in
how confident
would you be
that everything is okay based on what
the inspector can see i'm just wondering
if there are things that the inspector
wouldn't be able to see that could be a
hazard
trick question
in
many in many communities
we have professional inspectors and i
wouldn't have any problems with those
communities that have those professional
inspectors inspecting unfortunately in
new hampshire
there's a lot of communities that do not
have professional inspectors and they
don't have the education it's usually
somebody volunteering they don't have
the knowledge in the plumbing and the
gas and electric it's somebody that's
kind of doing everything i actually
think this might be another bill that
you that you might be uh
taking up inspectors or have taken up
inspectors
so
depends on what town or what community
you
that you're in and who's inspecting that
that
community i've seen
personally
situations that were inspected
and i they're against code i can walk in
i think anybody behind us can walk into
any house right now and find something
against code
representative marsh
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question you had said that you
were a licensed plumber i think i
understand uh looking at the statutes i
see that this bill is being put into the
rsa that deals with the state bureau of
fire control and this rsa that looks
like it used to require a plumbing
license rsa329a was repealed in 2013. so
do you in fact need a plumbing license
in the state of new hampshire you do you
need a plumbing license and a gas
footage license so in 2013
milia's law came into into play and the
mecha the plumbing board was
merged into a mechanical board with
plumbing and gas and that's where rsa
153 came into came into play
we're over at the fire marshal's office
from 2013 until july of last year
july of last year we moved from the fire
marshal's office over to the oplc
so we the mechanical board which
regulates the plumbers the gas fitters
oil insulation and water treatment is
now
administrated by the oplc
thank you follow-up
uh as a follow-up question it sounds
like you would recommend that we retitle
this entire section of law rsa 153
because it clearly has to do with more
than the state bureau of fire control
well to work on uh 153 to
clean up the language in the mechanical
board there is a there is a senate bill
that is
in process to clean up
to get the
to move the
language
in the
rsa from the fire master's office over
to the oplc
that is already in process i think it's
a separate type of issue that's going to
have to come forward
thank you
representative lekkas
thank you i just want to make sure i
didn't misunderstand you i thought i
heard you say that
um you thought somebody could do the
whole structure do the work on both
parts of a two family and rent them both
out
but the question is is that what you
meant because if you look at lines three
through five it indicates that the
person doing the work has to have that
as their primary residence
i'm sorry i didn't see that in line four
of occupied but still on a two-family
house you can occupy the first floor
and rent out the second floor
and
that person
that is renting who now rents from that
landlord from that landlord
and in today's day and age right now
with housing to be a big issue they
really have if that landlord is doing
plumbing or
gas fitting and it's and he's
let's say he's not getting promised
i'm going to tell you right now
permits are not something that happens
uh i would say
50 is what's happening out there from
what i see other people and inspectors
can kind of tell you that what's out
there
people do work without permits i mean
that's a fact and that's reality
the
if you're having somebody a landlord
living in the apartment and somebody is
renting from them
okay that person is going to be doing
work unlicensed
unknowledgeable
i'm in the trades i don't know
electrical okay i wouldn't even attempt
to do my own electrical work in my house
okay so
you
you try to do that with gas fitting okay
or plumbing i know everybody thinks
plumbing is just installing the sink or
installing the faucet but if we're not
inv if we're not venting that properly
people are going to get sick
you see people
all
all the time carbon monoxide is a big
issue that we're having it's very
dangerous
i don't like homeowners doing their own
gas fitting period but i understand in
new hampshire we want to do our own work
on our own house
and i understand that and i think our
association understands that so if they
own the house they're having a family
member
they're building an apartment for their
family member
fine okay let them do their own work let
them
put in here somehow i know it's in here
that the permit is required okay to do
everything by code i don't know how you
can strengthen that that would be
nice to figure out how to strengthen
that up
but
don't have a landlord on the first floor
and
and then
doing the work from the second floor
what happens in the real world is that
person moves in there for a month he's
technically living in there then he
moves out he does the work and he moves
out
that's what's happening out there all
right thank you
see no further questions
thank you for your testimony
mr nash
thank you madam chair and everybody else
i represent the mechanical board i was
voted to
represent them in this case
um i am also
a master plumber as well as
owner of plumbing outfit
we wanted to express that
we do
we do respect that somebody can do work
on their own house but we do feel that
there is a fine line that we have to be
very clear of and we feel this is going
to be a safety hazard for other people
beyond the owner of the house or a
potential safety hazard and we got to
put a line somewhere and we feel that
the line is that you can't
be doing plumbing work
with somebody else in the building
that's no not the owner of the house
very similar to
huh
we feel that if you're like as like
other people before us you feel very
strongly you own your own house it's
your own work you're the only person
living there we respect that very
greatly
but we got to put a line somewhere as
soon as it starts affecting other people
and we feel that this is going beyond
that work on your own house situation
that similar to what the other people
have said if somebody else is living
with you no association with you they're
just renting the space is you're
directly affecting them with work that's
not done by a professional someone that
doesn't have the knowledge in the trade
and um
you know with someone inspecting
something
there is a level of that they can't see
everything
and work being done by somebody that's
not in the trade you know things can be
missed and that's only if it's being
inspected
there is a high degree of
safety concerns as they mentioned before
carbon monoxide
issues explosion issues safety concerns
and on the gas side plumbing does have
its issues as well as not just sinks and
fossa repairs it could be
dumping into the wrong thing you could
have crossed water lines with um
you could have all kinds of issues going
on the house that could be safety
concerns but our biggest one especially
the gas
potential explosions potential carbon
monoxide stuff like that
questions from the members
seeing none thank you
mr mckinney
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is william mckinney
i'm the president of new hampshire
building officials association
again we represent over
building code officials contractors and
licensed design professionals for the
state of new hampshire
currently the new hampshire building
officials association does not support
house bill 1191 as written our primary
objections to this bill are the
inclusion of two family dwellings
we support
homeowners rights to do work in their
own homes their own single family
detached dwellings we do not support the
inclusion of two family dwellings due to
the inherent risk that can happen with
electrical plumbing or mechanical or
mechanical gas piping
it's often that we find in two family
dwellings although it seems very simple
it's just two separate dwellings that
you would have common mechanical areas
in a building which would include your
electrical your plumbing and your
mechanical gas gas connections your
heating systems and having one one owner
being able to work on those systems that
could impact another another resident of
that building outside of their family is
is a risk that i don't think we should
take on
yeah we need to understand that
there are skills needed in order to do
electrical plumbing and gas piping
skills that should require inspections
in all communities we've heard today
from other other uh
folks before me that there aren't
inspectors in every state in every
community in new hampshire and that's
true
nhboa new hampshire building officials
does track that statistics roughly right
now we have about a 50 percent coverage
for inspectors in new hampshire out of
those out of the 50 percent of those
communities there's a
large
number of those communities that are
part-time inspectors they aren't per
they aren't you know professionally
trained they aren't certified they're
do it as a hobby on weekends and nights
but they are called an inspector because
the community decide to have that so we
understand that you know to avoid the
risks to other residents
we should not be including two family
into this
exception
we also have a concern with accessory
dwelling units and i think the question
came up earlier is an accessory dwelling
unit creating a two family dwelling yes
it is
accessory dwelling unit is is a land use
term that you won't find in the building
or fire codes
it it is a
skirt around the codes in my view
when you when you were actually creating
a two-family dwelling and so when you
make an accessory dwelling unit and
under the current laws the accessory
dwelling unit can be rented so it's not
just your family impact you're impacting
you can construct a
an accessory dwelling unit and then rent
that unit the next day if you wish
that's that's a risk to somebody outside
of your family that i don't think we
should we should take on
you also have heard the terms house
flippers you probably heard the terms
airbnbs
vacation rentals by owner all of these
become an issue when we start allowing
people to do the work in these types of
structures
we work very closely i'm a code official
of over 20 years we work very closely
with with our homeowners when they're
doing work in their own single family
homes
often we find people that are that
aren't really competent enough to be
doing that work and we spend an awful
lot of time educating them and teaching
them how to do the work so that we know
that it's up to code
the concern we have is that we are now
going to be allowing these people that
may not necessarily be totally competent
now to do work into dwellings that could
affect someone else
not just themselves and for that reason
we cannot support house bill 1191
and i'll open to any questions
representative grota thank you mr
mckinney i i want to go back to your um
statistic that you mentioned so you so
did you say 50
of the municipalities in new hampshire
have
inspectors
by our latest our latest
tracking yes it's roughly 50 percent in
the state of new hampshire that has some
form of code enforcement
in their community
they may contract with an outside
company they may have a part-time
inspector they may have full-time
inspectors but it's roughly around 50
percent
follow-up yes
so though those communities that don't
have a building inspector
how do they
provide occupancy
permits for the buildings that are built
in those communities
well we know some communities
do offer occupancy permits
regardless of inspections being done
and then other communities don't offer
any occupancy permit at all
that comes down to how the lending
agencies or whether you're doing cash
sales on homes whether that
documentation would be required
the state statute requires that the
responsibility to follow code is left to
the contractor the applicant the the
person doing the work it's not
necessarily the responsibility of the
community to ensure that it meets code
unless they have inspectors
thank you
are there any other questions from the
members
see none thank you for your testimony oh
representative o'brien
thank you man i'm sure i did have one
and uh mr mckinney we could talk later
but basically
uh again coming from the boston area i
thought i i never thought i would say
you see the phenom of a three-decker
become a condo unit
and are we on the uh the dawning of this
happening in the state and we
should look at you know bills like this
and everything else with that in mind
because that would be three separate
entities in one building
correct correct and i think that's the
important piece of of holding this to
single family detached dwellings because
when we still start getting into
condominiums those are individually
owned dwelling units but they're all
attached
so i think it's very
important that we stay with the detached
single family
are there any other questions from any
of the members
thank you very much thank you
mr rancourt
good afternoon madam chairman and
committee members my name is steven
reincourt i'm a licensed electrician in
the state of new hampshire also a member
of the ecba electrical contractors
business association
and we're here to echo the concerns that
have come before us we're concerned with
the wording as it stands so we oppose
this as written right now there's been
some question about accessory dwellings
and as mr mckinney spoke there's a
there's a couple different requirements
for accessory roles that might minimize
it but if there was going to be some
further discussion about that we'd be
glad to be involved and help out but as
it's written right now we have a lot of
concerns with the the two family
because
in new hampshire it's live free to die
we've always believed that
as long as it's your family that you're
putting at risk not somebody else and
that was kind of the main principle of
all these exceptions and the electrical
as well so i'll answer any questions if
you want
representative scitec
mr rancourt this really isn't to you
it's to everybody
why should we even allow single family
think about this how can you put your
own family at risk if you're clumsy or
stupid or don't know how to do gas look
i do a lot of work myself
okay all right
are there any questions
for mr vancourt
seeing none thank you for your testimony
are there any other members that are
present that wish to testify for house
bill 1191
see none i will close the public hearing
we will now open the hearing for house
bill
1312 relative to water pollution and
waste disposal rule making
the committee recognizes representative
aaron
i've got some handouts
just getting myself settled here
thank you madam chair
thank you madam chair and thank you
members of the executive departments and
administration committee
for the record my name is representative
judy aaron i represent sullivan county
district 7 which is acworth goshen
langdon lumpster and washington
i'm introducing this bill today hb 1312
with regard to grease traps mandated by
the department of environmental services
to small businesses and other
and with regard to other plumbing
components
this past summer
constituents of mine who are owners of
balthazar's ice shack
were featured on wmur's tv news spot new
hampshire chronicles chronicles excuse
me new hampshire chronicles
it's a small local popular eatery on
route 31 in goshen new hampshire
the very next day des sent an expect
inspector down to the establishment to
do an inspection and they subsequently
closed them down because
the inspector said they didn't have a
thousand gallon grease trap
mind you
this establishment had already had a
license in place and had gone through
necessary inspections to obtain that
they had no grease issues with the
system they had already in place
and in any case they had a cease-selling
food until des was satisfied
that the issue they cited was corrected
and this was at the height of
balthazar's
season
now i'm not an expert in waste water or
plumbing nor do i know all of the
licensing requirements of des when it
comes to plumbing septic design or
installation
what i do know
is that some of my constituents have
complained to me that some of the rules
and requirements that the es has in
place are over and above what the
industry requires for these systems
one such measure of the industry
requirements is the international
plumber's code or ipc
new hampshire adopted use of the ipc in
our building code statutes in rsa 155-a
section iv
the ipc establishes minimum and
right-sized requirements prefer for
providing safe water to buildings as
well as safe manner in which the
liquid-borne wastes are carried out of
the building
many states use the ipc as their state
plumbing code
i don't see any problem in using the ipc
as rules or standards for plumbing and
septic here in new hampshire as it
relates to des rules especially since we
use the ipc in our own new hampshire
building codes
and i don't think anyone here today
is advocating for plumbing systems that
will cause damage or harm to people
businesses or the environment
be they within a structure or outside of
a structure
we all want clean water and proper
disposal of waste including and
especially grease
no one desires to damage their own
septic system or cause sewage haulers
and sewage processing plants problems
but we should also be cognizant of what
makes sense for the size of the
operation that smaller systems like
balthazars might require
we shouldn't be telling small businesses
that operate out of a 10 by 18 foot
trailer or shack
that they have to meet the same
standards as full-sized restaurants
they are totally different operations
i believe that des rules need to be
better
need to better assess and accommodate
small size businesses and work with
those businesses towards right-sizing
their plumbing and septic needs
this is why i think the ipc rules make
more sense
instead of a one size fits all minimum
of a thousand gallon grease trap
they should be assessing things like
water usage size of the sink usage of
the sink size of the kitchen space and
how grease is created and or handled by
the establishment
clearly smaller businesses have
different needs and operations than
those of larger ones
in my recent conversations with
representatives from des they even agree
with me on that point
balthazar's has friolaters that are
self-contained they don't put that
grease down their system
their patrons are given disposable food
containers plates and utensils so there
isn't a need to wash customer dishes in
a commercial dishwasher nonetheless
balthazar's was threatened through
revocation of their license to contract
and expend for the cost of a thousand
gallon grease trap which their own
plumbers and septic designers said was
oversized
based on the fact that balthazar's
doesn't generate enough water usage in
their system to keep the grease trap
from going stagnant that means the
system will be prone to breed unhealthy
bacteria odors and other problems i can
only imagine other small businesses that
have had this huge expense thrust upon
them and then had problems going forward
from it with regard to maintenance
then there are other businesses that
were forced to close or never even
opened because their establishment
couldn't do enough business to ever
repay back this sort of investment
i know of a dairy farm that wanted to
scoop some ice cream out of his shed
and the septic and food licensing rules
that des and dhhs have in place were so
onerous for this simple operation that
the dairy farmer backed off because the
investment was just unreasonable for
them
is this how we encourage
entrepreneurship
we need to take a serious look at what
we are asking of our small entrepreneurs
and whether some of these rules even
make any sense
in any case something needs to be done
and this issue needs to be addressed
a small 10 by 18 foot shack should not
have to install a grease trap that is
almost as big as the shack from which
they serve their customers
and please know this is not just about
balthazar's this is about overall
inequity and illogical and inflexible
rules that hurt small businesses across
new hampshire
there also seems to be an issue with
other businesses being allowed to have
an undersink grease trap and others not
perhaps des inspectors are not being
consistent with their rules
even though some people might think this
i sure hope that certain small
businesses are not being targeted
i also know some business owners and
plumbing professionals that didn't wish
to come and testify today because of
fear of reprisals and i don't think
that's a healthy environment for our
small businesses either
one last point
i had written the commissioner of des on
august 29 2021 requesting that their
rules be changed to accommodate small
businesses like balthazar's and to
include flexibility for small businesses
the response on october 8th was
we'll look at it
and that small businesses are already
differentiated by allowing a minimum of
a thousand gallon grease trap in this
instance
it's the end of january and they
apparently are still looking at it in
the meantime small businesses like
balthazar's may must comply
to costly and oversized rules
so i hope you'll consider what i've
presented today
especially through the photos that i
have sent around
and listen to some of the people
affected by these rules and what they
have to say
i'd like to see you pass this bill out
of your committee
it is time that we adopt the ipc as our
own rules and help our small businesses
be able to install systems that make
sense to the type of operation that they
run
thank you
and i'd be open to any questions
thank you representative aaron are there
any questions from any of the members
representative fellows
thank you
representative erin so your bill says
that
you're asking that the specifications be
no more restrictive than the
international plumbing code do you know
what the international plumbing code
would have said about this situation yes
and i have a copy of it here and they
have a chart that shows based on the
total flow through the grease retention
capacity
gallons per minute and so forth
what they recommend for certain size
systems
i'm gonna
share a copy of this with the clerk
representative o'brien
representative o'brien i'm sorry i was
thinking it was bailey that's that's
quite all right uh thank you
representative for taking my question
um
it seems something happened here
and
somebody made them put in a larger
grease trap than was needed i think
that's
i cannot you know understand that
but where was the negotiation with the
you know the plumbing inspector or
anything else like that if you say it
exists
in the plumbing code now why couldn't
that you know particular business
petition the plumbing inspector to try
to
uh make the amends it's you know because
the thing is is this a state issue or a
local issue that went awry
i think thank you for your question
representative o'brien i think this is a
state issue because of the way the rules
are
for
des and licensing for these
establishments
i would like you to ask that same
question to the owners of balthazar's
when they come up and they um
and they testify
because then
you can ask them exactly who they spoke
to and how they tried to rectify this
situation
but basically my understanding is that
des came down they did an inspection
they looked at the system they said we
need you to put in a thousand gallon
grease trap
and they had to comply or have their
license revoked
at the height of the season
are there any other questions from any
of the members
thank you representative aaron thank you
mcguire
thank you madam chair members of the
committee carol mcguire merrimack
district 29 allenstown epsom in
pittsfield
and
i wish to reassure
representative o'brien that the thousand
gallon grease trap
is specified in the des rules
for
restaurants attached to
the restaurants that have sewer systems
have septic tanks
it's a thousand gallons regardless the
size of the restaurant
and
i happen to be part owner of a
restaurant that has a
septic system
and i was talking with the
with our co-owner and he says we have
two 750 gallon tanks grease traps
because
it's a very expensive
extra treatment septic system
and they don't want it to get
contaminated with grease
but
the most important thing is
the maintenance
he pumps those tanks the grease traps
twice as often as the
manufacturer recommends to make sure
they don't ever overflow
and trash
our quarter million dollar septic system
that's
it
and the that's the problem with the rule
just saying a thousand gallons because
it doesn't allow for
extra maintenance efforts it doesn't
allow for very tiny restaurants it just
says a thousand gallons period no
waivers no exceptions no nothing
and i think that kind of one size fits
all rule
is not appropriate for this sort of
thing we have restaurants of widely
varying size in the state
from you know an ice cream shack or
a homestead operation
and putting this kind of
rigid requirement by rule is
inappropriate in my opinion so that's
why i co-sponsored the spill
i'll answer any questions i can
are there any questions for
representative mcguire
thank you representative
is there mr nash
thank you madam chairman and members um
i'm not representing the board in this
one i'm just representing denron hall
i've come across these situations a lot
where you have a small establishment and
you have the two opposing forces the
the plumbing code covering the structure
and then the thousand gallon interceptor
outside i personally had to deal with it
with a
in a different state but i've had to
deal with it um with just a household
kitchen but it was part of an assisted
living where they bring food up and they
were concerned and then once they saw it
they
they did back off in the thousand gallon
interceptor but i i fully believe in
that it's not a one size fit all
situation and that the plumbing code is
it'll help size the situation
it also does a better job of protecting
the plumbing within the structure so if
you're going to go with one the ipc is
better for that so that way you start
the protection right at the point of use
instead of just outside the building
representative o'brien
thank you manager i'm trying to wrap my
head around
this and maybe
the thousand gallons when
maybe like i say if it's in one code it
could be smaller
is it something to do like
you know we were taught as firefighters
it's occupancy
is the key
is that have anything to do with it in
other words there's a fear in the future
okay you could probably get by with the
500 gallon grease wrap but that doesn't
mean the next guy
10 years from now
you know because like in the case of the
occupancy with the firefighting i could
have a store that i sell brick out of
but then i load it up with blankets i
get a different fire hazard so
the point i'm trying to make
and you know i don't know the good cut
off of it i think there is a nice gray
area there as far as that occupancy is
tough and change of use with uh business
i think is what you're getting at like
um
like if you have uh
i don't know like a pre-pre-packaged
foods versi they throw an oven in now
it's a bakery or something like that and
um
i i don't know if there's something for
that i do know i've come across those
situations where you literally just have
a kitchen sink a fridge and a microwave
and
they were going to make us put a
thousand gallon interceptor in outside
just because it happened to be part of
an assisted living complex
but luckily when they walked through
they realized that it was smaller than
their kitchen at their house and they're
like they're just appointed to use
grease interceptor then as far as actual
laws and um coming up with a uh
a compromise i'm not sure what that
would be but as is right now i can
totally understand where these people
are coming from and if i'm to support
something at least the ipc has you
covered and they have a
a varying degree of capacities instead
of just a one-size-fits-all situation
representative scitec
mr nash what's a
dentin hall what is that
sorry that's me mumbling i'm with den
ron hall
we're out of manchester new hampshire
they were plumbing and hvac company
representative fellows
thank you
i'm just wondering if if you need
a grease trap for a restaurant a small
restaurant and you know in this case
maybe they don't need one but if you did
what are the consequences of
putting grease down the drain
and
like what's what what happens what's bad
what are we trying to prevent
yeah yeah roto-rooter um but the
the reality of it is only as good as its
maintenance to back to what i said
before with anything you don't take care
of the outside it's going to be bad for
you you don't care if the inside grease
interceptor is going to be bad for you
so what you're trying to stop is the
build up of excess grease in the pipes
and the septic area i believe it's the
leech fields getting all clogged up and
not a good breakdown you can actually
get the pipe it could start off this big
and you end up with just a tiny hole and
it's hard hard stuff that's built up
inside of it if it's not maintained
properly
and you can get if you just have a
thousand gallon and grease interceptor
outside and you don't have the proper
stuff inside then you can still have
that issue with the inside structure
that's why if you're going to have one
for sure it's definitely the ipc to
cover the inside
um i don't know if i answered you
correctly
follow-up
yes so is it grease trap required for
home septic systems
no they're they're for
i mean
if you have a fry later and you have a
lot of grease going into it i guess but
it's really just for any situations
where you have a lot of grease dairy
stuff like that
are there any other questions from any
members
seeing none thank you very much
thank you everyone thank you
renee pelletier
usually people don't want to hear me so
i don't push that button
so for the record rainey pelletier i'm
the director of the water division at
des
and i think the
des personnel that representative aaron
was talking about was probably myself
and some staff
so i think
i'm going to try and add some clarity
here
the ipc climate plumbing code has
nothing to do with on-site wastewater it
looks about interior plumbing it tries
to determine what you need to protect
your interior plumbing as far as what
goes into the ground on the wastewater
side which is what we regulate
ipc does not deal with that they can
recommend certain size grease traps for
the type of facility you have
as mr nash i believe said to make sure
your pipes don't clog and so forth but
clearly ipc has absolutely nothing
to do with on-site wastewater so i hope
that that adds some clarity to that
i think also i'm
as far as i know i'm not sure that des
was the individuals that went to the
ballot says i'd be interested to hear
who that personnel was but here's how
the system on the statewide level works
if someone is going to open a restaurant
of any size type whether it be an ice
cream stand
or whether it be a restaurant to service
fast food sandwiches
has grease and so forth and so on they
need to get a food license from hhns
so once they get a food license every
year they're reinspected to see what
their premises are look at cleanliness
and those types of things
and also if there's been a change of use
so if that happens they come to des
there's some correspondence with them
that asked if in fact their septic
system was approved for the type of use
that is being proposed or changed to
i think what happened at this
restaurant we're talking about now the
one that representative aaron referenced
was that they went out and did an
inspection and it had been changed from
an ice cream stand to serving food
and more importantly food that in fact
had prior layers in that type of issue
so hence when that was brought to our
attention
then as a minimum you're required to
have a grease strap
grease has a lot of
terrible
attributes if you will for septic
systems
what we've seen lately in the last few
years
and we're all for entrepreneurial
businesses small businesses however big
or small they would be
but in some situations people will go in
they'll lease a space
un unknown to the
lessee
they could put in a russian put in
greece
if in fact their septic system fails
depending on the size of that system it
could cost the owner of that building
somewhere in the twelve to fifteen
thousand dollar price range
grease is what we call fog fats oils and
greases
that's what comes out of a place that
has a high grease load depending on the
food that they're servicing
so it's an important issue
it's as much of an important issue for a
person that owns a system that may go
into failure especially if they're
leasing the space to someone else
or to anyone else the system clogs
and if it's a large commercial system
like representative mcguire was talking
about you could be looking at 30 40 50
000.
now the shack we're talking about not
that order of magnitude mind you
but in fact it is an issue
we have dealt with oils fats oils and
greases for years we do it on the waste
water collection side
if it's a municipal wastewater treatment
plant it's important about how that
waste is processed
and more importantly it's it's just as
in a financial issue for the person that
owns the building or the septic system
that it's in so
if i might madam chair i'd like to bring
up ray gordon news with me he's been
dealing with fog
if you will for years
and i think maybe if you can give us
five or six minutes to give you a little
primer
on
the disadvantages if you don't properly
maintain
fats oils and greases if that would be
okay with you
absolutely
thank you
so my name is ray gordon i've worked for
the department of environmental services
for 27 years
and for two years i've been at the
winnipesaukee river basin program
running the state-owned wastewater
treatment facility
and
uh for 14 years i worked for the
wastewater engineering bureau
and it all started with the um
commission to study ways to encourage
proper recycling
and disposal of grease trap waste back
in 2007
and i learned a lot on that legislative
study commission
so as a result of that the state was um
given the task of educating everybody on
grease trap issues and i created a
six-hour training program for wastewater
operators and wastewater systems on
grease interceptors and as well as a
three-hour class for subsurface and i've
certainly stayed on top of the topics
over those years
and the international plumbing code what
we find just has minimum standards so
it's a matter of how much water is
flowing and what's the minimum size
grease interceptor that you need
in order to primarily protect the
plumbing of the building and some states
like massachusetts have actually
mandated internal in some communities an
internal grease interceptor to protect
the plumbing and an external one to
protect the
uh wastewater collection system whether
it be a wastewater
sewer plant like i run or a
septic system
so
the biggest thing is you got two size
interceptors a small one that has a 30
minute retention time a large one
that could have a 36 hour retention time
and each one of them has its pros and
cons
and from the wastewater side we're
always balancing that with the
restaurants around the state and we have
a mix of the small devices and the large
devices on our sewer systems all through
the state
but because it is so much more important
on the septic system side the department
over the years went with the thousand
gallon tank
and the
issue with it is
is it's all about the grease that needs
to be disposed of
and it's basically a storage vessel
for the grease to be removed and there
are very limited areas which is why we
limited areas for disposal which is why
we did the study commission to try to
encourage more disposal of this grease
because there's two things that are
going to happen with this
first off the waste systems can be
damaged if you're not storing the grease
and removing the grease from that
interceptor on a frequent enough basis
and then on the other end if the grease
is passing through into the septic
system
then that septic tank when it's pumped
could be rejected from
a wastewater treatment plant
and that contaminated load would have to
find somewhere else to go i only know
one facility down in rain and mass that
like septage and greece together
right now we have facility in allenstown
that takes greece south berwick maine
but there's really limited disposal for
the greece from the greece interceptors
now i've gone out inspecting greece
interceptors with many towns around the
state of new hampshire
and what we see on the small devices for
disposal
is sometimes their yellow grease
containers which is that fry grease it
never comes in contact with waste water
it gets put out back and it gets sent
off for recycling
and they can put some of that grease
from that grease interceptor in there as
long as they're not contaminating it
enough the renderer allows them to do
that
other folks maybe are throwing that
grease in a dumpster
and you know that's kind of frowned upon
because it could leak and cause problems
but it does happen
but really the best option is to take
that grease and send it off for proper
disposal
to a disposal location and that's
typically done by a septic hauler with a
large truck
and you know it's way more economical to
store the grease in a thousand gallon
tank and have a truck haul a thousand
gallons at a time maybe every three
months every six months
than it is to do the proper maintenance
on the small
grease interceptors which the story i
was told the training was that they were
developed by the military to be emptied
every day
and that's a lot of labor and time to
empty them every day to make sure you're
getting maximum effectiveness
and then where's the grease going to go
when you empty it you need some other
tank to store it in to have someone come
and and haul it away
so that's just a brief summary of the
grease interceptors
and what we see i'd be happy to answer
more questions about it
representative schuett
thank you madam chair yes um
representative aaron's bill uh refers to
the international plumbing code
that the
components shall be no more restrictive
than the ipc
however i thought i heard you say
that the ipc codes are a minimum
which she is referring to i would say
would be a maximum level
um
which is what
yeah so the international plumbing code
there's a chart in it it says you've got
15 pounds i mean
15 gallons per minute coming out of the
sink so that's the flow rate
then
you have to have 30 pounds of storage
for grease
so you only are able to store 30 pounds
of grease at a time with a faucet that
gives you that much of a flow
and a lot of the manufacturers of grease
interceptors are giving you more
capacity in their grease interceptors
when you look at the rating there's a
there's a chart that they give you
because they know it's all about the
grease storage
and the way i understand the code that's
the minimum and then many towns around
the state
have
sewer use ordinances
which
can be more restrictive than the
plumbing code
and some of them will add in thousand
gallon tanks or there's even automatic
devices that will remove the grease
on an ongoing basis so you don't have to
hand
empty them
representative allegro
yes thank you
i'm a little bit confused here because
at the end of the day all code
you should never say all or always but
essentially all code is about minima not
about maxima
so
like for instance
we built a house the code said that a uh
electrical sockets had to be
at least one every six feet
the code didn't state anything about
forcing us to have four every six feet
so code is about minima so i'm not sure
i understand
your argument here
right and that's where i'd refer to the
others in the department because on the
wastewater side we have a collection of
both larger
thousand gallon interceptors and you
know the smaller under the sink ones in
our collection system
follow-up
but those are each for different
circumstances right
it's not that they're saying you could
have
excuse my ignorance of the terminology
but one thousand or two thousand for a
situation it's that you have one
thousand for this situation and two
thousand for that situation so at least
and by definition at least
means a minimum
so the ipc codes of course naturally are
going to be minimums right
for me
yeah i think i want to get us off this
concept of the ip soda and on-site
wastewater they are totally irrelevant
to each other
it is a concern to us if the plumbing
code has an issue and people's pipes
clogged so forth and so on
what we regulated des is what comes out
of that structure
and goes into a septic tank or an
increase in separate if you will or not
and now a minimum of a thousand gallons
tanks is correct that's a minimum if
you've got a hundred seat restroom
you're going to have a much larger
grease trap and i think representative
mcguire mentioned
that they had twin 750s
and that's because on a
flow basis as ray described to
representative
anything of 15 gallons a minute or more
you need this size grease trap again the
ipc code is addressing the interior
plumbing
not the waste water issues that in fact
is what we regulate
so you do have minimums for grease traps
for sure
but you also have numbers as the flows
increase all of what we do in the
wastewater world is based on flow or
discharge if you will you know from a
single family home that you were talking
about you we have design flows
that are
conservative standards for 150 gallons
of bedroom per day that's what's
designed we don't need to tell you you
need 200 gallons per day
because we figure your average flows are
going to be probably less than 150 and
that's very similar to when the ipc
looks at grease traps
they look at the size of the of the type
of business what they're going to be
discharging how many gallons per minute
would go and they recommend sizes for
interior grease traps that's where this
issue of minimum came
let's say that you were lucky and you
had a bedrock welded and you could push
30 gallons a minute out that grease
strap in size would no longer be at that
minimum and that's how the ipc regulates
that totally different from the way we
calculate flows that come out of a
structure for wastewater
representative schmidt then grota
thank you mama chair
so 16 years ago when i was on the
environment and agriculture committee
i inherited a study committee
from a
very nice colleague in my committee who
didn't run again the next time and what
it was called the fog committee
fat oil in greece
rainey remembers that
so
one of the things that was the period
where yellow grease was going from
costing the restaurants to have it
hauled away
to getting paid for the yellow grease
because they were learning to
recycle it
the nasty stuff
that brown grease
restaurants produced was still costing
an
arm and a leg because
it's you know
couldn't be used for anything and it was
um
really really disgusting stuff
really i had a whiff of one of them one
time and i'm going like that'll do it
for me for the rest of my life
and these people have to deal with those
dang things
every day because that's what they're
producing
and we look for the possibility because
brown grease
does have
some
energy potential if you could if you
could get it representative schmidt
could you please ask the question
so i have to give a little bit of
background so i understand so
we found that there was a
uh a device a procedure that was able to
turn brown grease into usable form
but my understanding is that it actually
and it was going to produce
you know
not it costs you
more to get the stuff uh the byproduct
than it was the byproduct was going to
be worth well nobody wants to do that
so
this procedure was going to
was going to
make
the stuff that was going to be more
valuable than the cost of making it
my understanding is that that's still
not being really done
so what happened to that procedure it
was being done out at keene state
college what happened to that procedure
yeah i know a lot of the alternative
like energy uses when the market kind of
went down and gas prices went down a lot
of the alternative energy uses of things
like brown grease is just kind of
petered out they couldn't be sustainable
please state your point of order
are you able to perhaps
with all due respect quickly answer the
representatives questions so we can try
to stay on topic
yeah i just thought i did the price went
down and those
processes weren't viable and they they
just didn't go anywhere so there was
some biodiesel and some other things
there was a thing at keene state college
and they just all petered out because
it's about 16 cents a gallon to get rid
of the grease from a grease interceptor
representative grota
thank you
um
so
[Music]
the purpose of all this
right
one of the reasons why we do this is
because we want to protect our
groundwater correct
so
if we didn't want to do that
it would not be important
to maintain our septic systems or keep
them from failing
correct
so the end result of all of this is
because we want to protect our
groundwater
yes and by the very nature of the septic
system that's what they are designed to
do that's correct okay
so last question i'm sorry i had so many
questions i never looked over
so the grease trap
is that
in
parallel to the septic system or in
series
the grease trap would before the waste
gets to your tank and then from the
septic tank it goes to the leash field
thank you
representative pearson
thank you madam chair we i've heard
we've all heard multiple times now that
the ipc is not the appropriate code
to be addressing this what is the
appropriate code
i think the appropriate code is the 1000
rules that des oversees that regulate
septic systems online on soil wastewater
i would not want to rule out the ipc for
the interior plumbing i think that's an
important part of the process
but from once that waste leaves the
building and goes out your four inch
pipe
that comes under the
thousand regulations on the 485.
thank you
okay so the thousand rules that you're
talking about here that des
uses those are internally created or
those from a national standard those are
created and we go before jlk when we
drive so it's internal okay correct
representative bailey
thank you
um we've heard a lot about flow rates
and grease receptacles and all of this
but
where this began and the testimony we
heard and what this picture shows is
that they have zero graze grease and
zero flow rate so why do they need
and also that if you didn't have this it
might cause a ten to fifteen thousand
dollar expense
and yet i'm thinking
that must have cost a pretty penny
so
why would you need all of this for zero
grease well
madam chair good
[Music]
uh i'm trying to see as i talk i think
when you look at their menu that they
have food that produces grease
now greases greases grease is grease now
how that's disposed of we have no
control over
so
when the
hhns folks went out to issue a new food
license they noticed that there was a
change in menu
hence that was brought to our attention
and we saw that the system was not
designed for greece so
that's
what i know about that
talking with the concrete folks and
septic system installers to install a
grease trap the cost of the trap and the
installation somewhere around two
thousand dollars
so
i don't know what people are paying but
that's what we got from several people
that install tanks and systems
thank
you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking questions
um
first question i have is
we hear
that the international plumbing code
that deals with the internal
plumbing
goes by flow rates when they set their
minimum standards
is there a standard flow rate
for getting to a thousand gallon
outside
tank
no we don't have a typical flow rate for
that
follow
i'm not asking whether you do is there a
standard out there that deals with flow
rates and the size of tanks that are
available
now that i'm aware of
follow up follow up
is a thousand
gallon tank a
the smaller size they make or do they
make outside tanks in smaller
dimensions generally that you could get
a 750 probably
but we look at a thousand gallons
because of the longevity of the tank the
in frequency of pumping required because
every time you have a tank pumped you're
probably looking somewhere around 300
so if you get into a larger tank which
is that minimum of a thousand
financially
you know the tank may cost a little more
but you'll certainly recoup that cost
because you won't have to bump this
frequently that's where we establish the
1000.
one last follow-up
do you know what
surrounding states require for the same
setups
do they have minimums minimum standards
for these outside grease traps
yeah massachusetts is a 40 hour
retention time a thousand gallon minimum
tank
and i think vermont
is similar to us but the one i remember
is massachusetts
representative scitec
um
what's this retention time what exactly
is the flow rate have to do with it
what is the flow rate exactly
so the retention time that's the time
when the water enters the tank till it
leaves the other end
and that is what gives the grease the
time to separate
some greases will separate quickly
such as the small interceptor is 30
minutes protects the building because
it's taking out that grease that'll
adhere to the pipes immediately
where the 36 hours allows more fats oils
and greases to settle out
so that it does not impact the septic
system with the full load of those fats
oil and greases
did i hear flow rate what exactly is
that
that's i know that what that is for
well but
what's what's that mean for a restaurant
well be the you know the gallons per
minute as it comes in you would
calculate how long that gallons per
minute
would take to sit in the
three gallons per minute is a rating
like two-bedroom house or
uh what you how you would size a septic
tank for a two-bedroom house a certain
size restaurant has a certain flow rate
is that all right it's a figure of merit
yeah septic systems are designed on
based on flow rate and that's based on
let's say if you had a restaurant how
many seats you have and what kind of
services you were providing that gives
you a baseline flow rate
hypothetical because of your number of
seats in the type of servings your
ultimate flow rate that are going to
dictate that 36 hour retention time are
going to be based on if you went in and
left the sink running for 10 hours
you know so what we design flow rates
for the leech field hydraulically to be
able to take that water
representative pearson
okay
so looking at this particular situation
that triggered all this
could this not have been handled by a
device a trap
a collection unit internally and not
something that would have had to been
colossally created into this yard
could this have just been handled with
something under the sink
well i think as we talk with
representative aaron i think depending
on the menus and depending on what we
would consider the flow rates
i think that would be something that
certainly could be entertained over time
it's not our goal at des to stymie
entrepreneurial businesses but we also
have a responsibility to protect the pro
environment protect the people that have
a large investment in the septic system
whether it be this situation which is
the individuals that are discharging but
many of the situations we arrive at
that's not the case
and many people go in
unbeknownst to them
and and not understand what the ultimate
result will be and the cost associated
with it so i mean there's several
nuances i guess one could entertain
um and i think we
when i had my conversation with
representative aaron we thought that we
could certainly take some time and think
about it
but this bill presents a real problem to
us we think it's inappropriate to have
ipc even in it
we have some real concerns about that
code for the drinking water side of the
world as well
so i i think we're always open to have a
conversation about
minimizing costs but maximizing the
benefit so
the answer is a long answer to your
question but i think we could certainly
talk about that
but i don't think it's a legislative fix
okay so
[Music]
when dealing with this particular
in other situations where you're
at least from the lay person asking for
something that seems extraordinarily
ridiculous do you guys work and present
the other options that are available
for these folks to look at you know this
is
you know we're not we're not talking
about buffalo wild wings here clearly
right so
i mean are you working with these folks
or is this are we dealing in absolutes
no i think if anyone we we pride
ourselves in having
pre-application meetings for any changes
anybody wants to make whether it's a
residential whether it's commercial
we don't care this is a situation
where
the health and food inspectors went out
there was a change of use they brought
it to our attention the septic system
did not
qualify for greece and a change in menu
and then
that's how it moved on
but certainly anybody could call us up
and saying hey i'm providing i'm selling
sandwiches but now i want to sell fried
clams what do i need to do what are my
options
we that is always available always
and that just didn't happen in this
situation
representative on zara
thank you thank you for taking my
question i have a lot of them um
over the years here
um
with the existing system in place it may
have been answered earlier
was this
again was this new system needed
and
was this
prior system in the first
photo here was it capable of handling
like it was alluded to in the last
representatives question of handling the
new grease load i guess you could say
no the answer to that would be no i'm
gonna pass around
the menu
and i want you to look at the menu and
see in fact from uh knowledge of what
you consider generates grease
nope
are there any for are there any other
questions from any of the members in the
committee
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony gentlemen representative
fellows are you waving your hand at me
senator fellows
so i i was surprised to hear you say
that you're going to estimate the amount
of grease that's going to be going into
the septic system based on the menu
because if they're doing a lot of fried
food i assume that you're taking that
grease and it's being recycled you're
not pouring that down the sink are you
i would i would almost think that you'd
be getting more grease down the grain
from the ice cream that you had to begin
with because when it melts you put it in
the sink
so and and representative fellows
i believe that the
question i believe that the gentleman
that is sitting next to representative
aaron
does plan on testifying and whenever he
is testifying you can certainly ask him
any questions that you choose so i'm
asking them
why you think that the menu is important
to look at because you seem to think
that that means that they have more
grease going into the septic system
and i haven't seen it yet but if you're
basing that on a lot of fried food
i'm thinking that that
fried food grease probably isn't going
into the septic system a good question
representative fellows if i had the
opportunity to hire staff to go and see
everybody's behavior and how they handle
their grease that would be a different
story we don't everybody does it
differently depending on what they're
looking at
when we seed foods that when cooked
generate grease we assume
that the grease has got to be handled
and maintained somehow whether it be
anterior grease strap or exterior we
have no way of
monitoring how people handle that grease
we know there's a potential it concerns
us
from the septic system side the
environmental side
so that's why the standards are set the
way they are we do not control behavior
we just control and look at what is
being produced and served
and however they choose to add longevity
to their system or not
is up to them but with our minimums
we feel comfortable that the environment
is protected and also when you think the
long-term maintenance of the tank the
frequency of pumping which i talked
about earlier at the end of the day
that's why there's a thousand gallon
minimum
you're welcome
are there any other questions from any
of the members
matt madam chair could i
i don't want to take this hope
i i do have some real concerns about the
ipc language in this bill
on the drinking water side
as you may or may not know the drinking
water systems have a lot of what we call
backflow presenters so if there's a
negative pressure in the system that
wastewater doesn't get sucked back into
the drinking water side
that is a big concern for us having that
language in this bill with the ipc which
i think at the end of the day by the
both on the water and wastewater side is
inappropriate
thank you very much thank you
mr sherman
this gives new meaning to the term hot
seat
my name is philip sherman i'm the chair
of the building code review board and i
began by intending to respectfully speak
in opposition to this bill
well at the same time now not
necessarily disagreeing with
representative aaron or representative
mcguire's statements
and well respectfully disagreeing with
some of what was just said from the
department of environmental services
as it stands this bill violates rsa 155
a
part 2
which prohibits state agencies from
varying modifying or waiving the
requirements of the state building code
which includes the plumbing code unless
approved by the building code review
board leading to the required
ratification by the legislature
based on the international plumbing code
definitions of plumbing system
building sewer
and water service pipe
the scope of the plumbing code extends
to the public sewer or the private
sewage disposal system otherwise known
as a septic system
and to the public or the private water
supply including the piping that gets
them there
in the last
hour or so two hours i've heard three
different definitions of where the
plumbing code stops
what i read in the book
what i hear from des and what i heard
from the plumbing licensing folks who
think it stops at a dotted line 10 feet
outside the building
i think we may have a problem with
simply how the various regulations here
sew themselves together so that may need
some work
the plumbing code
again using the definition in the book
provides detailed requirements for both
exterior and interior grease traps
called grease interceptors in the code
and similarly provides detailed
requirements for other plumbing
components which are referenced in the
bill
the des currently has the authority to
submit any changes they desire to the
bcrb
but no changes to the model code were
proposed in the 2018 code package
because they read the international
plumbing code a different way
nothing prohibits the des from creating
their own permitting review or approval
package based on the technical language
in the plumbing code
this bill and this is my critical point
this bill would allow the des to amend
the state building code without going
through the normal amendment process
which results in ratification by the
legislature provided the requirements
are no more restrictive than the
plumbing code
and would most likely lead other state
agencies to request the same authority
this would lead us farther away from the
desired one-stop shopping provided by a
statewide building
code those were my prepared remarks
and the situation has got it
increasingly cloudy from my limited view
of things uh by the way being new to
this position six months ago
and i and i do think that there needs to
be a conversation between the parties
involved the des and bcrb and probably
the plumbing licensing folks
and try and figure out what the extent
is of the various regulations
because clearly there's a disagreement
there right now or at least
each one is reading them properly in
their own
own context
so i would hope that we could have some
time
to come back to this committee ideally
with some agreement as to where this
dotted line ought to be and who ought to
write what rules
although that may be opening a very
large can of worms
other than that i have nothing to say
representative pearson
in my world uh what you just did is
called throwing a grenade in the room
my apologies no no no it's uh apparently
very necessary
and i think you're right
based on what i've heard here um
we clearly have an interpretation war
going on
but at the end of the day
what we're talking about here
is
absolutes
and
to give you give a practical example of
that absolute when i when i was in
oklahoma city
we had a standard response for fires in
a restaurant and anybody that's ever
seen a waffle house on the side of an
interstate knows you can only fit about
16 humans in it total including the
cooks that response generated 41 firemen
so
we couldn't even physically all go in
the place but again absolutes it's a
restaurant
so what i'm getting at here with this is
that you know it seems to me that we
have some circumstances here that really
require some discretion
and i don't know if this is a lack of
flexibility by the es they may not have
it this may be a jail car issue to deal
with with some of this but
right clearly
we've we've applied things literally to
situations that really don't warrant
them
so i i would certainly encourage and ask
that if you
if any of the three groups here have a
concept as to how to
look at this more reasonably to to
please bring it forward because
this bill is not going to do it
no
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
i just
want to clarify i can
make sure i heard what you said that
there is
in code
sizing for
both internal and the external
interceptors as you call them
there most definitely is i'm not
prepared i'm not a plumbing engineer so
i'm not prepared to speak to the
technical details of anything that's in
the plumbing code but the definition of
grape grease interceptor clearly applies
to interior and exterior
furthermore the international code
council
publishes more codes than the state of
new hampshire adopts and they publish a
code on what they call private sewage
disposal systems septic tanks
septic systems
and
the plumbing code and their sewage
disposal code are melded they know where
those begin and end and it begins at the
entry to the sewage disposal system
so
in terms of how our code is written i
think it's fairly clear and i confirmed
this with two other people with more
experience this morning
how it fits together with the des
regulations i think need some work and
we need to have a conversation and
certainly happy to have it i do not
think there's a war because a war takes
two parties and at least
it's a conversation that needs to happen
i agree
are there any other members that have
any questions
representative scitec my question my
question is i don't know whose side i'm
on here
there's an aggrieved party we haven't
heard from yet that seems to have been
shut down almost preemptively without
any
i then i hear from des who seem to be
very accommodating trying to live within
their rules and we'll talk but something
didn't work and i don't know how we're
going to have this i'm just this isn't a
question i'm taking advantage here we
need this conversation somehow because
everybody's wonderful but it didn't work
out that way
i suspect the executive session will be
very interesting
are there any other questions
from mr sherman
thank you
thank you very much thank you
i do not have
any more pink cards but i do suspect
that the oh
gentlemen wish to testify
that's okay
yeah
thank god
i apologize that i could not read this
last name so whenever you take the very
hot seed if you could just please
identify yourself
hi my name is troy berryalt this is my
wife
karen
and we own balthazar's ice shack
actually she owns balthazar's ice shack
i'm professionally employed
could i trouble you to please spell your
last name
b-e-r-r-i-a-u-l-t
french pronunciation yes
please go ahead
uh what would you like to know
well
testify to your story i i must say that
i did see your head shaking yes and no
several times so hopefully you took some
notes and you can clear up some of the
questions that may have if there's any
specific question that was asked by
somebody if you want to address that but
start with your story okay sure let's go
with price we're a small business and
price is a big deal for a small home
business to start now we already went
through the pricing we put we installed
it i've been working in construction for
40 years i work for a multi-million
dollar construction form timberland
construction i'm very familiar with
plans
bid processing you know goes across my
desk on a continuous basis so my wife
asked me to step in when they said put a
40 gallon grease trap and i said well go
just do it well uh a thousand gallon and
uh she says well
would you look over the plants
and that's when all this started
because when i looked over the plans i
started researching grease traps there's
be colds and i come up with uh well this
is gallons per minute
i said they want me to put a thousand
gallon grease trap and separate in a
separate excuse me
and in the ground and i said okay fine
uh
but we only put out 14
uh gallons per minute
they want me to put a thousand gallon
interceptor which cars for 50 or more in
my case is 250 or more with a thousand
gallon
so i said well this is this is over
engineering that's at its best and i
deal with this all the time at work over
engineering and when you over engineer
something you always have problems and
it's you look you can look up over
engineering just problems
always has problems so i was looking at
this going uh it's you know this is not
right so i started fighting with the dc
yes about it i says well we only put out
14. you want me to put a thought why
i said so i had my uh septic system
inspected this is no grease well we do
fried food most of it's fried food well
if you're more today's more than
kitchens in modern restaurants
they're not there cooking a steak on a
grill
they buy you know if you if you have uh
everything's frozen and pre-cooked
so when we put in the fry later it's
already pre-cooked there's no greasy
foods doesn't no i'm sorry we serve on
paper so again
it's all self-contained uh we have table
talk fry later is it self-contained
there's many places that you can send
the grease to
well not the grease that oil to
because they recycle it a lot of them
permit it
you can reburn oil get oil burners i
could put one in my bond if i wanted to
and take it and heat my bond there's
reason you can recycle the oil and burn
it as a fuel
this is you know a class
i think is class three or class five
fuel which are considering that and the
gentleman put up a brown grease brown
grease is traded on the market today
so it does have value
and a good point because i you know
that's something i also researched after
i got into the whole grease thing
as far as our licenses go
we when we first started this
we were going to ice cream and some food
and like i said i'm only a 10 by 18 18
shed shack whatever you want to call it
i can't put all that much
uh it's so we started it and the lady
that came and inspected us i says well
can you inspect our kitchen in the house
because i would like to do soups and a
few things and she says oh no you have
everything here
because we had the three base sink the
hand washing station and she was you're
all set what are you gonna you know a
couple hot plates maybe a fries i said
you had time put a couple
countertop fry laters you're gonna be
self-contained i said yes this is not a
problem
it says you don't even need
a grease trap i said you sure i'm
putting in a full
well the reason when we bought the house
uh
i checked the septic system like i said
i'm i'm in construction i know i know my
way around most things in construction
and i found out one of the pipes led
right down to the river
i said good lord no this is horrible it
happened when one of our grandchildren
took a bath and they emptied it out and
i smelled something down by the river
and i found a pipe leading to the river
i said well i capped it and i tore up
the whole system
and i put in a an advanced septic system
in
so it's more you know i'm a little bit
i'm a little bit of a tree hugger i
don't admit it where i live but you know
i'd uh
i believe in uh you know equality and
you know clean rivers and all that so
what we did is we put an advanced system
in
um
so i put the system in but when i was
putting the system in for because i
asked how much do i need for a ice cream
scoop because they have to have
i think it's 350 gallons a day
goes through for an ice cream ice cream
scoop
and uh
they so i had to put in a certain size
system for that and i said do i need a
grease trap
because i had everything torn open they
said oh no you're fine so i said okay
great so we started doing what we were
doing
and then uh
a person that lived in goshen
that was a select man was a selectman
he called the state now he he likes
doing uh septic systems that's one of
his things but he owns a trailer park
one of those trailer parks in new
hampshire actually
well
he called the state he made a complaint
saying i didn't have a grease trap
and he knew i didn't have crease hats so
when they sent the next uh
food handles license
it said ice cream only now it's i don't
know if you you get these you take them
you you slide you slide it over into the
glass you hang it up and you say okay
it's down because we already had this
so then he sent somebody over to look at
it and says well you only have ice cream
only so i called the state
i said let's take care of it they said
okay the
pandemic hit
everything was a little bit crazy back
then we were the one the only places
open to serve food
now we we actually uh volunteer some of
our so my wife cook soup during the week
and so with the fire department and we
serve it throughout the community
for you know we just do that you know to
help the community out and so we had
these functions going already and uh
so we didn't hear anything from anybody
i called the state just radio silence
from them and i you know said what well
uh
actually the person i was dealing with
the state was very nice they were kind
the ds was very nice to me
i said we'll get this straightened out
and stuff and i go okay
so i you know so i wanted to put a type
of uh grease trap in anyway i says well
let's run a groove strap all i wash is
like a pan and in three or four tongs
because it's all self-contained
i mean i cook hamburger but the
hamburger has a top griddle it has a
grease trap on it
so i just take that and dispose of the
grease trap
we all have wood stoves here in new
hampshire we know where that can go
i mean for a lot of different things
when you wipe it out with a rag
wall with a paper towel you know you can
burn it or whatever because it is
secondary fuel anyway
but uh
so i had that done and they they find
out they came we uh we went to the
pandemic and then we had the uh
what was the uh
that came
oh chronicle came so chrono came so it
was a big deal i mean chronicle's
showing up we have fitz coming in this
was a you know it's a big deal to us
we're very small you know a little hole
in the wall everybody laughed when we
first opened it up because nobody was
showing up i don't advertise anybody
it's just word of mouth my wife's a
professional chef once they get a get a
hold of her different you know specials
they're like oh my god this is great and
we keep the price down because we live
in a
uh not the richest area i like to call
we're on the uh
the shadow of mount sunapee that's where
i live we're on the other side of the
mountain
so
well anyway they come up and they come
down whoa you need a grease trap i go
okay fine we'll install grease trap in
here you know what it i checked out 14
gallons we need a 40 pound grease trap
it's not a big deal they come back oh no
no no you need a thousand gallon
incinerator
well this is and that's when i got
involved with the septic that's when i
started getting involved and i did a lot
of research on grease disposal of greece
interceptors how large how small they
says oh
i talked to do yes and i says okay this
is ridiculous a thousand gallon i said
it's the size of my building
i says and never mind breaking ground
and what it's going to cost says well
you can get a 500 but you're limited to
what you can do
and i go well the difference between a
500 cement one and a thousand
is zero volts 300 in price but you still
got to break ground you still got to buy
the same pipes
you gotta you gotta the labor and
another thing they don't you know you
have to have it designed
i mean they said well this last time
it's two thousand dollars it's fifteen
hundred dollars just to get a designer
out there design it before you even
break ground it's twenty five hundred
dollars just for the cement thousand
gallon incinerator that's without pipes
now you're gonna have people come down
and put it in
now you have to have a richted uh
septic designer
put put install the system and that's
going to cost you money
so you know the money keeps on piling up
i don't know where people are getting
these prices
i mean what they've told her
you know a number occasion the des the
waste manage is they they've underplayed
this so much
i i understand that you know hey i want
to have clean water
i mean the biggest thing is you know
they're talking about grease grease dams
which happen in the cities
because you have grease dams that's what
they run across these grease dams and
they have a big problem with grease
because you have different facilities
do different amounts of grease but they
have people that come and inspect your
facility they know exactly what you do
how many people you serve it's it's all
on you know they all come and expect
that they know what your menu is they
know if you serve on paper if you serve
on plastic
you know we don't have no seating zero
seating at our facility they knew that
we served strictly on paper i don't
serve any styrofoam because it's bad for
the environment i pay extra for paper
in fact i try to get recycled paper as
much as possible and very very little
plastic with my plastic forks and spoons
i'm next to gunnison lake i don't want
people going down there and leaving uh
trash down at gunnison lake i want to be
able to
road if they do
if anybody's seen one of those staff
from comps in the woods you realize they
just last forever but we're very
conscious and it's that this is my story
and this is what we've done
so i hope this helps
did you see a copy of them of the menu
that was passed around you have that
this is your menu okay yes
representative fellows
yes can you just tell me what was
you you did install what they asked you
to install
yes we're 100 right now we have all the
permits we're not here for us at this
point
this is
it's over engineered and that drives me
crazy
so i guess we're just here because we
don't want
we want to try to fix it so that it
doesn't happen to somebody else okay
do you want to share how much it cost
you to do this
sure uh
it was fifteen hundred dollars for the
uh designer
it was another
twenty five hundred dollars
for
the pipes in tank
and then it was another four thousand i
got a good deal because i'm friend of
mine four thousand dollars to install it
and i
this was on that i got the uh a good
deal without readings we actually have
their uh
we have their maple syrup so i got a
good deal on that
representative linsara
uh was this menu being served on the old
system and if so for how long
were there any issues yes it was uh we
had this for close to what two and a
half years
well not the whole menu i mean we've
added as we've gone the menu goes
because fried foods fried food i mean
you can go with uh
chicken wings chicken drums and it just
add you know it's the same thing it's
the same process
but uh yeah and i had my septa tank
inspected by certified inspector that if
that installs you saw absolutely no
grease after we've been running for at
least a few years i'm basically close to
the same menu
representative allegro
thank you madam chair i uh i have to ask
i'm really curious i'm looking at the
picture but it's hard for me to discern
can you give me an estimate of what the
actual dimensions of that grease trap
are
just rough
oh i want to say it's a good
eight
eight feet by five feet by
maybe eight feet maybe ten feet by eight
feet by five
that's close enough thank you
representative bailey
thank you
the missing piece for me seems to be
such greases you're making isn't going
into this right
no that's so this is all compl
everything about flow rates and size of
tanks it's all completely irrelevant
right
yeah it is but to be honest with you why
it says we should protect you know
environment so the flow rate it's what
you have if you have a three base sink
it goes by your dimensions so if you're
three three basic like mine is 10 by 14
by
and that's three bays and then you have
a hand washer station which is also 10
by 14 by five so they take these
dimensions in and that gives you the
gallons per minute that goes out
so i do 14 so
whatever i wash in there it's you know
it's only i can only if i fill them up
and dump it's only
14 gallons per minute that's most i can
possibly do or possibly push out i mean
what a lot of people are not taking into
consideration is
some industrial fry leaders they have
they self-clean excuse me
this is where i'm getting confused when
you start talking about flow rates a
flow that's not happening
yeah gallons per minute yes but i mean
it made it sound as if it's not going
into the system at all
no the gate no it's a that's
at one point you alluded to maybe you're
using it to enhance your firewoods well
no i mean you have you have the oil and
what you do i have my fryer latest my
friday is a bench top okay they're
self-contained they they only your real
industrial ones actually self-clean and
self-pump mine only don't do one my
basket does one serving at a time
that's it i have three of them three
table tops the only about this big does
one's one serving of french fries like a
mcdonald's french fry bag lodge one
serving that's it
and that's you you reuse your your oil
over and over again and when it gets
when it gets old i actually hand screen
it and put it back in and when it gets
too wall i put it in the container and i
bring it right down the street we're a
person that recycles it
so that never touches the
sink that would be insane to pour it
down the sink
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair thank you for
coming here to testify
how long have you had this installed now
i know probably as this year that was
installed
yes well we got this installed in
september
and since september
have you looked at all to see how much
grease you've actually collected in that
short time frame yeah i have a lot of
grey water in there
there's no grease thank you
are there any other questions from any
of the members
representative grota
so when you originally started your
restaurant
was it
primarily an ice cream shop
or did it always have ice cream and a
little bit of food
always ice cream and a little bit of
food that's why we put in that permit
for uh for both
follow up
and when did you start expanding your
restaurant to include
more food
oh
uh our menus increased a little bit at a
time with the same type of things since
we we opened
i mean you always increase a little bit
but as far as what we had in there for
cooking has been the same
follow-up yeah so because i look at this
menu and
i'm not a restaurant person
nor do i
can conceive how i would go about doing
all this but
there seems to be
a
like a 50 50 ratio of food to
ice cream
of offerings
you can't see this
the board goes further with more ice
cream yeah well that's what i'm thinking
right
and last question
if you
for example
the fryers are one thing but wouldn't
there also be
cleaning and grease with
[Music]
don't you clean all the
well actually they that we do but they
also make inserts for the shaping dishes
which are plastic inserts where you pour
in because who wants to be washing them
all the time and you pull the plastic
piece out
so yeah there's very to little none i
mean today's modern kitchen there's very
little cleaning there's a lot of things
you can cook in but the chaff and dish
is what we put our things in uh like the
cheese and whatever we use out there
yeah it goes into a it goes into a
plastic container in the chaff and dish
itself the liner and then you pour in it
you can look them up they're very cheap
and it's a lot easier on everybody
okay are there any further
questions from the members
i i have a little bit we're also
representing uh the bed and breakfast we
have we have a place up the street which
is an end they have a 750 gallon grease
trap that's already installed and they
were told they can't operate because
they don't have a thousand gallon
they couldn't cert you know they could
serve the public
which is to me that
i i don't understand that
thank you very much for coming today are
there any other members from the public
that wish to testify for house bill one
three one two
correct yes this is be very brief i just
don't want you folks to lose sight of
the issue of the ipc
in the drinking water side i know this
conversation has been
primarily focused on wastewater but we
have some real concerns about the
misinterpretation of the ipc code with
backflow prevention
and water systems that's a really
important issue for us
that is a big big concern
because it could put thousands of people
at risk if in fact we have backflow
thank you madam chair thank you
see no further questions there's nobody
else to testify i will close the hearing
for house bill one three one two
uh
thank you
is
the better job
oh
representative grota
you